hey friends how's it going welcome back
to deep dive what you're about to hear
is an interview that i did with logan
yuri logan is a behavioral scientist
turned relationships therapist who has
written a book called how to not die
alone this is an absolutely fantastic
book that i made a video on a few months
ago and that video was called this book
changed my love life and it's got over a
million views to date logan is also the
head of relationship science at the
dating app hinge where she leads a team
of researchers to help uncover what are
the secrets behind finding and
maintaining true love in our
conversation we discuss all things
dating and relationships including the
concept of the friend zone does it exist
doesn't exist how does one break free of
this proverbial friend zone we talk
about how to apply insights from
behavioral science to the world of
dating how to optimize your dating
profile and how to think a little bit
more like a scientist when it comes to
dating we talk about things like what
makes the perfect date we talk about the
concept of the secretary problem the
prom date versus the life partner and a
bunch more exciting stuff i had an
absolute blast during the conversation
initially we had like a two hour slot
where we recorded the remote interview
but we had so much stuff to talk about
that we chatted for another two hours
afterwards as well so i think this was
probably the longest podcast interview
that i ever did anyway links to all of
logan's stuff including her book how to
not die alone are going to be in the
show notes and the video description or
if you'd rather not read it although you
should you can check out my video
summary of the book but anyway i really
hope you enjoyed this conversation
between me and logan yuri so hey logan
welcome to the podcast uh it's it's
great to have you hey
um thank you for having me i'm so
excited yeah thanks for being on here we
managed we we connected because
initially i mentioned your book how to
not dialogue it's very good i mentioned
it in my email newsletter and somehow
you
clocked that i'd mentioned it and then
you emailed me which was pretty cool
and now here we are having a bit of a
chat oh that's great yes it was my
friend joe garvey who gets your
newsletter who sent it my way so thank
you to joe for connecting us and i've
been looking forward to this for a few
months now amazing um so i'd love to
start like i have so many questions
about dating and relationships and stuff
but i'm very curious about
about kind of your background like how
did you get to the point where you now
work at hinge and you have a book about
relationships like what was what was the
story yeah so i've always been really
interested in dating in relationships as
i think many people in general are
i definitely think part of it goes back
to
my parents getting divorced and one of
those seminal moments in childhood and
adolescence where you think okay happily
ever after it's not something i can take
for granted and i think it planted this
seed in my mind where i thought this is
something i really want and i have to
work for it so from a young age from my
teens i really thought
this is something that i want to
investigate more it's mysterious to me
and it's not a given then i went to
harvard and i studied psychology and i
had a secondary concentration in women
gender and sexuality and so i was able
to understand things like gender
dynamics i did a large paper on
pornography habits i really just use it
as an excuse to get into whatever
topics were interesting to me
and then from there i went on to work
for google i had a couple interesting
jobs there i ran the pornography team
there was called the porn pod this is my
first job out of college and it was
running the
ad campaigns or the online advertising
for
some porn companies and sex toy
companies which honestly was just like a
very quirky thing to talk about with my
family during my first thanksgiving home
but truly my my job at google got very
interesting once i started to run this
team called the irrational lab
and so are you familiar with the book
predictably irrational by dan ariely
i've heard of it i've heard a lot of
people reference it but i've i've never
read it what is what what's the deal
with the book yeah it's a great book
worth having on your radar so
behavioral science is this entire field
that looks at how people make decisions
and why we so often act against our own
rational best interests and so it might
be something like of course we should
all be saving for retirement we agree on
that but why is it so hard to take a
certain percentage of your income and
put it towards savings or we say we want
to lose weight but then we don't
actually show up and exercise or eat
healthier foods and so there's this gap
between who we want to be what we want
to do and what we actually do and this
field investigates that gap it says why
are we acting against our own best
interests and so i had the opportunity
at google to work with dan we ran this
team together called the irrational lab
where we really thought about
the behavior of people who work at
google the behavior of google users the
behavior the behavior of google
advertisers and it was just so
interesting to apply this academic field
to real world marketing culture
other aspects of a company and so that
is an important moment in my
development because
i later did that with dating and
relationships and so at that moment that
i was running the irrational lab i was
single i was using dating apps i was
swiping and i thought okay this is
something very new no one has done this
before nobody has swiped on thousands of
people and gone on eight dates a week
and it just felt like this new moment
and i was surrounded by all these smart
people at google but they were as lost
as i was on dating and so what i have
done
in the last majority of the last decade
is basically take thoughts about dating
in relationships thoughts about
behavioral science and how we act
against our own best interests and
combine them and so what i've been doing
through one-on-one coaching through
matchmaking through writing the book
through working at hinge is this whole
field where i'm saying actually
relationships are a series of decisions
and you can break them down and you can
make better decisions
and get into a great relationship or you
can repeat the same bad decisions and
wind up in an unhappy relationship or
unhappily single and so i really try to
take this academic research-backed
approach that will help people get out
of their own way overcome their dating
blind spots and get into a relationship
oh amazing okay so i have so many
questions on this but i wonder if can we
pretend like we're having a one-on-one
coaching session
and sure
i would love to do that amazing so
what's what's the sort of person that
comes to you for like is it like
relationship therapy or like dating
coaching like
how how how do i decide that hey let me
book a session with with logan yuri
yeah it's a great question so i have
worked with couples i have one guy i've
been working with for years where first
he came to me when he was single i was
helping setting him up on dates i was
helping him after those dates then he
got into a relationship and now i coach
him individually and her individually
and the two of them and they just got
married and are having a baby and i'm
seeing them next week and so i've really
gotten to be there for the entirety of
their relationship but
most of my clients are people who are
single and send me an email that says
something like
i like my life i like myself
i like my job i like how i show up to
friends and family
i am an engaged person in the world this
one part of my life is not working i
don't know why and i want to enlist your
help to improve it oh interesting okay
so that sounds basically 100 like i was
before i discovered your book
[Music]
um interestingly so
when the this episode is probably going
to come out in a couple of months but
um
i actually have a girlfriend now and she
was the one who recommended the book
because
we went on our first date like sometime
in july and she said that she's been
reading this and i thought okay that's
an interesting title let me read it as
well
and now we're like together and we're
applying a bunch of the principles that
you talk about like um kind of being
intentional about like reviewing the
relationship and asking that that you've
got this questionnaire like later on
where you're asking asking questions and
stuff it's all really good but
uh up until then i was very much of that
the exact avatar of that person that you
described broadly happy with my life
life is good relatively successful by
kind of traditional metrics but i can't
seem to get into a relationship um and i
also i kind of felt that
i'd been on a bunch of dates but
the thing i'd always be asking my
friends afterwards is like how how do
you really know if you like someone i
don't i don't know i don't know if like
i didn't really feel a spark i was like
all this kind of stuff so
how how how do we go about like solving
this problem what sort of questions
would you be asking
oh i love that well thank you for
sharing that the book has been helpful
it's very meaningful to me
usually when i work with clients the
first session is really understanding
who they are in context and so
sometimes people just want to come in
and within the first minute tell me
everything about dating but
there's this coaching exercise called
wheel of life where i understand you
know what's going on in your career
what's going on in your family friends
mental health physical health and that's
helpful to me because occasionally i
have clients where a lot of stuff is
going wrong and i really try to help
them
figure out those other things or i say i
think you should invest in a therapist
first and then come to talk to me and so
just understanding that dating is part
of an integrated system but let's say
everything else really is working except
for dating then we dig in we try to
understand so one thing i would ask you
early on is what is your long-term goal
for
dating right now oh okay so i think um
i want to get married and have kids and
get a dog and stuff
and
when you're young it's like easy enough
to just not be in a relationship because
life is good and et cetera et cetera et
cetera but i kind of think that as like
middle age approaches um in a way a
relationship is a hedge against
loneliness to an extent i'm not sure if
that's like actually true but i think it
would be cool to have a family and have
kids and stuff and
all of their studies well a lot of the
studies show that
being in relationship and stuff
contributes to meaning and happiness and
fulfillment etc
so it feels like even though for me it
is not like an urgent thing right now
that i absolutely am desperate to find
someone because i'm really happy with
myself and my life i know that i
probably should start looking given that
this is a thing that i want further down
the line yeah that that answer really
resonates with me because sometimes
people hear the title of my book how to
not die alone and they feel like it's a
critique on being single and if you are
single and it makes you happy and long
term you want to be single that's
totally fine but i find that many people
do want to find someone and the majority
of people around the world do end up
getting married so this is obviously
something that our culture's still
investing in and yeah the research shows
that our health happiness and overall
life satisfaction hinges on the quality
of our relationship so it's a great idea
to hedge against future loneliness
through through dating and finding
someone and i think having gone through
the pandemic people who were single and
spending a lot of solo time i heard from
many of them and they said things like i
wish i had invested in this before or i
thought that love was just something
that would happen for me and now i'm
going to more proactively go and get it
and so i do think we've just gone
through this major traumatic moment as a
culture and it was the jolt to the
system that many people needed to take a
step back and say
i do care about this and whatever
psychologically has been holding me back
from saying that out loud i'm going to
say it right now and i need help and
accountability and advice to make that
happen
nice so so that's my kind of long-term
thing a hedge against feature loneliness
i should probably take it seriously in
the short term where where do we go next
from there we're going to take a little
break to introduce our new sponsor for
this episode which is fabulous fabulous
is the number one self-care app to help
you build better habits and achieve your
goals and genuinely it is probably the
single nicest app that i've ever seen in
terms of its design and its aesthetic
and the illustrations and the imagery
it's just an absolute joy to use i'm
using the app personally for two main
things that's number one building better
routines and number two being a little
bit more mindful rather than kind of
like frantic all the time and so in
terms of building better routines the
first thing we're working on is building
a better morning routine and so i've got
these little like achievements that i
have to do like drinking water first
thing when i get up figuring out a way
to have a great breakfast in the morning
dance dance your way which i've not yet
unlocked and the idea is that it sort of
turns it into a game so i need to take
the box that i've drank water three days
in a row and then it will unlock okay
cool once you've built that habit now
let's think about the breakfast thing so
it's good in that it's based on
behavioral science insights and it's one
step at a time but the people that built
habits using the app were more likely to
stick to those habits than a control
group and there's kind of two approaches
that you can take if you're using the
app number one is that if you already
know what habits you want to build you
can use fabulous as a kind of
beautifully designed habit tracker and
then you can just like set your little
challenges set your habits and you can
take them off as you go along it'll send
you notifications at the appropriate
times of the day when you need to do
that particular habit or the alternative
way of using the app is actually using
their guided habit coaching method where
they've got particular programs that you
can use to make yourself more effective
like exercise or coaching or deep work
or meditation or ambience or yoga um and
yeah they've got these things like sun
salutations intros and salutations like
it just sort of really guides you step
by step through whatever that thing is
that you want to improve in your life so
if any of that signs up your street and
you want to join me on this journey of
building better habits with this like
beautifully designed app then head over
to the fab dot co forward slash deep
dive that's t-h-e-f-a-b dot co forward
slash deep dive or hit the link in the
show notes or the video description
wherever you are watching slash
listening to this and the first 100
people to use that link will get 25 off
the annual premium subscription so thank
you very much fabulous for sponsoring
this episode so in a coaching session i
would try to understand why you think
you're single and so before we would
have met for the first time i would have
sent you some homework to do and one of
them is to ask your closest friends and
maybe family why they think you're
single
and so the reason for this part of it is
to
there's this whole idea in behavioral
science that we have these blind spots
we have parts of our behavior or our
ways of thinking that we don't have
access to and so if we only talk about
what we know i think we're missing this
part and so through my feedback through
my pattern matching through asking your
friends and family why you're saying all
things will come out and so people often
say to me i thought everyone was going
to say that it's because i don't
dedicate enough time into dating but
actually consistently everyone said that
i have unrealistic expectations or
everyone said that i'm too picky and so
even in that pre-work i think people get
a lot out of it because our friends and
family want to help us but there's not
really that many moments in our society
for people to pull you aside and say hey
logan by the way i consistently see you
making excuses about exercise or i see
you saying you're unhappy with your job
but you don't change it but if you
invite them into a safe moment and say i
will not hold this against you why do
you think i'm single i think people will
will want to share wow okay so i think
if i had done this exercise my friends
would have said i have unrealistic
expectations and i'm too picky i guess
this is a thing that you get quite often
yeah and of course there's a bias for
what kind of person books time with an
expensive dating coach but yes i i do
think that that's very common and the
too picky thing comes up a lot
so we would talk about that and then i
would go through your relationship
history and i would say you know have
you been in a relationship before
and i don't know if you want to talk
about this like live on the podcast but
you know have you been in a relationship
before how long have they lasted where
have you met the person
who tends to end it i would just want to
understand kind of up until the moment
that we're meeting what your
relationships have been like in the past
and what i'm doing in the background is
pattern matching okay do i hear him
saying that he's putting effort in and
it isn't working do i hear that the
problem is he's not even going on dates
at all do i
believe his reasons for why things are
working out or do i want to dig in more
and so i'm basically using like hundreds
of
people i've spoken to in the past to say
like what type of data
are you and then figuring out
a plan of action to help you based on
you know how you're showing up to me
that day okay and so within this cohort
of people who pay for an expensive
dating coach what what are like the
common the common problems that you see
in like you know
in in this world
sure so in my book i talk about the
three dating tendencies and that was
based on the people i had been seeing in
dating coaching or kind of friends and
other people that i was meeting and so
that whole framework which i know you
talk about a lot in your video is based
on unrealistic expectations and so i saw
the most of the maximizer and the
maximizer is the person who has
unrealistic expectations of their
partner and i have a feeling based on
you and your background that you're a
maximizer yeah very much so when you
when i read that bit where it was
describing maximizer i was like damn
okay
i feel really pulled out right now
yes totally and so if you're listening
right now and you're not familiar with
this a maximizer is the person who says
you know life is one big research
project and i can research my way to the
right answer and there is a perfect pen
and there is a perfect microphone and
there's a perfect zoom setup and if i
just research my way to the right answer
i will win
and sometimes that works there is you
know the best microphone but
with dating there's no way to date
everyone there's no reviews humans are
what we call experiential goods you have
to live them to know how they impact you
and what some person might like in a
wine or a movie is different than what
you might like and the same thing is
true with dating and so you really have
to get out there date different people
and make a decision for yourself there's
no researching your way to the right
person eventually you have to choose
someone great commit and build a
relationship so on that note um
there i i was earlier today i was
listening to an episode of the hubermann
lab podcast where he speaks to dr david
bus i think is his name who's a big kind
of researcher in this field and talking
about
yes there is an extent to which uh kind
of mate value and dating preferences is
subjective but actually there's a lot of
stuff that across cultures is kind of
true and across the culture that we live
in where
you can actually sort of rate someone in
terms of their mate value and get a
somewhat consistent result for an
individual person across a bunch of
people that you that you look at so
they would argue it's not quite as
simple as you know there's someone out
there for everyone and just as like
there are zillions of different
combinations of wine there you know some
people like different sorts of people
like
to to what extent does that side of it
come into the equation here like in
terms of the stuff guys look for in
girls and and vice versa
yeah so there's a ton of interesting
research in the academic field of
relationship science that studies things
like attraction or do opposites attract
or if thousands of people rated the
attractiveness
of certain people would they all find a
consensus and generally the answer is
yes so i can make my point a little bit
more nuanced which is assuming that
you're dating people who are a
reasonable match for you people
with whom you have interesting
conversations people with whom you're
attracted people who you could see a
long-term relationship
a lot of maximizers come to me when
they're already dating in a pretty small
pool of people all of whom would make
great partners but instead of taking a
step back and saying
of the last 10 people i went out with
there's actually a bunch of them in
there that probably could work long term
and it's about me choosing investing and
making a relationship they think the
fact that i don't feel a hundred percent
sure about anyone means that i need to
keep looking and so i think it's really
about what's the premise well first of
all i don't think there's any a hundred
percent sure about anything especially
with something as meaningful as getting
to choose one person for the rest of
your life which is what many of us are
going for right even with the job it's
like millennials gen z we think i'll
stay in this job for 18 months there's
with dating it's just this huge decision
that we are making with so much cultural
baggage and so
of course we want to make the right one
but also it's it's very hard to be sure
so really with maximizers i want to help
them switch their mindset from if i keep
looking i'll find the perfect person to
relationships are things that you build
not things that you discover
and so life is much more about having
high standards finding somebody or
something that meets that standard and
then feeling good about the decision
versus the maximizer mindset of i'm
obsessed with making the right decision
and i think that that's a recipe for
unhappiness i was quite familiar with
this line of reasoning because i had i
was a big fan of alanda baton stuff
around like romanticism and yeah how the
soulmate stuff is a bit of a myth and
actually um
one of his quotes that i really like is
that compatibility is an achievement of
marriage it should not be its
prerequisite and so
i i kind of came across this stuff a few
years ago and i kind of like
maybe i was bullshitting myself but i
genuinely thought to myself that hey
i i recognize intellectually that
a bunch of the um the value of
relationship comes from the amount of
effort you invest into it rather than
pre-existing compatibility and finding
someone who ticks all of the proverbial
boxes
and so i'd be going on these dates and
i'd be like ugh i'm not really feeling
it but
i don't know maybe i'm just being too
much of a romantic maybe the whole
feeling is a bit of a myth like
so
and and this was the thing i would i
would always ask my friends and never
get any useful responses to it's like
what is the bar like how do you know you
like someone enough to warrant investing
into that relationship
and like how like what are the questions
i should be asking in my head about like
you know i'd be thinking do is this the
sort of person that i would enjoy
spending 16 hours in a row with if we're
stuck in an elevator together it's like
i mean maybe that's a question is it
someone i'd want to go on holiday with
for an extended period of time
yeah what what are your thoughts on this
no this is this is great and i think the
more personal we can make it actually
the more universal and easy to
understand it is and so why don't you
tell me what are some of the questions
that you were asking that you felt
weren't very fruitful and then with the
woman that you're dating now
what shifted so that you felt that you
could see the potential
and
you could invest in her and so what was
that shift like for you
i think before the questions i was
asking were
things like
do i feel a spark as it were
um which was always a bit like vagues
like how do you define the spark and
it's like uh you know it's it's kind of
like that question of asking like how do
i know i'm in love when people are like
well
you you kind of just do you know when
you you know yeah um so that was a
question another question was
um am i looking forward to seeing this
person would and am i looking forward to
seeing them again another question was
um did i wish this date lasted longer
um
another question was can i imagine
having dinner with this person 10 000
times in my life
um
another question was
how
well do i feel this person reflects on
me when i introduce them to my friends
and family
um
but a lot of these weren't like
conscious initially
it was just a
with a bunch of other people i'd i dated
i just had a general feeling of like uh
i'm not really feeling it but maybe
maybe i'm just being too picky so for
this for this current girl that i'm
dating it's really the the thing of i
look forward to hanging out with her and
i have so rarely had that particular
feeling of looking forward to seeing
someone in a romantic context
that i'm like oh hello this is new is
this what people mean when they're like
you've gotta find them i love that so
it's interesting you know you shared
earlier that you
were introduced to my book around the
time that you started dating her and so
your experience of evaluating her has
been somewhat in the context of reading
my book right and so it's hard to
separate what's her from what's your
mindset and it's probably a bunch of
things and it's her mindset right she's
actively choosing you what i could say
in terms of people that i work with is
that i get a lot of messages that say
i used to focus on the spark i used to
focus on instant chemistry and a feeling
of i've known you for my whole life and
if that wasn't present i thought okay
next it's on to
the date the following day things like
that but instead people are shifting
away from i need to feel the spark to
what can we build together
or am i curious about you
so one of the things that really
resonated with me in the book was the
idea of um the secretary problem and the
whole explore versus exploit dilemma and
i'd i'd come across this before but the
way you framed it in terms of age was
the thing that i'd like i'd never heard
before i was like damn because i'd
always sort of thought like
how how how do i know what n is how do i
know how many people i would actually
end up dating my life therefore the
whole thing is flawed i wonder can for
the people who haven't heard about it i
wonder if you could give us an intro to
the secretary problem and how how that
relates to this
issue that some of us have been being a
maximizer
absolutely i would love to share that
and i'm glad to hear that it resonated
with you and i also want to give a shout
out to the book algorithms should live
by which is how i was first exposed to
this idea so the secretary problem is a
line of mathematical inquiry so it's
sort of a math puzzle that asks imagine
if you were hiring let's call it an
admin and there were 100 possible
candidates so you know how many
candidates you have and here's what's
hard about it you have to interview them
one at a time and after each one you
have to say yes or no i want to hire you
or i don't and so the question becomes
how many people should you interview
before you choose someone if you choose
too early on maybe there's tons of great
candidates out there and you haven't
been exposed to them but if you choose
too late what if all the good candidates
have passed you by and so the
mathematically correct answer here is
that you interview the first third of
candidates so the first 33 and from
there you say who is the single best
candidate that person now becomes your
benchmark the next time that you find a
candidate who you like as much or more
than that person you hire them because
the 33 percent gave you a chance of
what's a chance to see what's out there
now you know and then you snag the next
person who's on that level
so are you following me with that
great all right so how do we apply that
to dating well
we don't know the total number of people
you're going to date and it's really
going to vary but let's say that we
think about age and let's just choose
that
let's say you in particular you are
going to be dating in earnest from ages
18 to 40. what do you do
um with that number well you could say
well what's 33 percent of that and so
mathematically we know it would be at
26.1
years of age that's when you've dated a
third of the people who you could
possibly date and so you look at those
first years of dating and you say who
was that benchmark person who did i date
who i liked as much or more than the
other people and now in the future when
you meet someone who you like
similar to your benchmark that's the
person you invest in and when i say this
to people sometimes they say oh no my ex
was so great should i contact her right
now and i say no no it's more of a
concept it's the idea that you likely
have already dated somebody who is be
great most of us are past that 26.1
years of age mark and the idea is it's
not about keep searching and searching
and not knowing it's about understanding
that you've probably already dated
somebody who would be great and the next
time you meet someone where you have
similar feelings that's a chance to
invest and build a relationship yes i
just i just love this so much because
like this was the exact answer to the
question that i've been having the
problem i've been having for the last
few years which is that i felt that oh
maybe i just haven't dated enough people
like i didn't date that much when i was
at university but and i you know i had a
bunch of female friends all that all
that kind of stuff
and i always thought that okay maybe
when i'm 30 or something that's when i
will have dated enough to get that kind
of sample size to then kind of know but
then when i saw 26 i was like oh my god
okay i'm already 27. okay let's you know
really start taking this thing seriously
um
i've done it i've mentioned this to a
few friends um a bunch there's
um a bunch of my friends are like not
into they're very much hesitators and so
they haven't really done the whole
dating thing
um do you think that
getting to like is having female friends
a sufficient like
sample for this sort of thing or do you
think that it really does need to be
actually going on dates like first dates
through an app like hinge or whatever um
or even in real life god forbid um to to
get to gather the appropriate data
points for this for this problem
great so for people who aren't familiar
with the framework there's this idea of
the hesitators is one of my three
tendencies and basically these are
people who aren't putting themselves out
there they're not going on dates and
their framework is all date when i'm
ready which might mean losing weight
getting a more impressive job having
better stories to tell maybe a global
pandemic is over but there's always the
dot dot dot all date when and my whole
philosophy is no you need to be dating
there's two main reasons why one is you
only get better at dating by dating and
two is you only figure out who you want
to be with by actually being with
different people and seeing what side of
you they bring out and so i understand
the crux of your question which is can't
you get some of those dating skills by
having female friends or can't you get
some of the who do i want to be with by
having female friends
i would say
it will help you it will help you
develop empathy it will help you
understand what kind of conversations go
well or how to be a better listener i
think it's part of a well-rounded life i
do think that there's something unique
about being in the romantic realm
i get so many questions from
men and women who say i'm always
friend-zoned so there might be and these
are very gendered terms but you know
there might be the woman who says like
i'm super sporty i grew up with brothers
i always played sports i'm one of the
guys but then when i you know go in for
the kiss they're like no i see you as a
sister or a friend and same thing
there's the guy with tons of girlfriends
who is the person you call after a
breakup but not the person that you
sleep with to get over the breakup
whatever it is and so often people want
to get out of the friend zone and so
what i would say is
in general having friends is extremely
important it helps you be a well-rounded
person it makes you happier it's a way
to meet new people but there is
something different about engaging with
people on romantic and sexual terms that
you do need to experience specifically
through doing that and so what is it
like on a date to present yourself as
not just one of many people who that
person could be friends with but as the
one person who they might choose to
invest in and what does it mean to
experience a hard conversation with the
one person who you're in a romantic
relationship with and so for those
people i would say yes
and you should also be dating got it um
so okay so at this point in our dating
journey we've had had the consultation
with you we're like all right cool i'm
gonna be dating
i should probably and at that point
probably can be thinking okay cool i
guess you know i guess i should make one
of these accounts on one of these dating
apps potentially oh i've got to figure
out my photos ugh but now i have to
choose photos of me that look good oh
but you know i lost a few gains during
the pandemic maybe i should go to the
gym for a few months like
what what are the what are the action
steps that someone in that position
would take
oh i love this yes okay so you know you
know you and i have met very first
session i've heard why people think
you're single i've heard about your
dating history and now i'm going to give
you
some experiments to run and so my whole
thing is date like a scientist so date
like a scientist is have some hypotheses
test them
bring the data back to me and we will
try to understand what that means and so
maybe at the end of our first session we
said we think you're a maximizer we
think that you have unrealistic
expectations of partners and we think
that the next time that you go in a
second date and you don't want to go in
a third we're going to push you to go in
the third because it's in that third
that you will deepen the relationship
and get to know this person versus
rejecting them for something silly
if your issue was that you were a
hesitator and you weren't putting
yourself out there your next step would
be getting a dating app and
trying to go on more dates
and so what's the point of a dating app
profile
the point is to
create a great first impression
and so your dating app profile is almost
like you walking into a bar
and giving off a particular vibe so if
you're wearing a game of thrones t-shirt
people are going to engage with you on
that if you're wearing a tutu or a
basketball jersey people are going to
engage with you in different ways and so
how do you want people to see you and
then respond to you and so i can get
into the weeds but
really your dating app profile should
tell a story it should have variety it
should say this is me when i'm with my
family and friends and this is what
dating me would look like this is a full
body shot of me so you can see what i
look like in the world here's a clear
picture of my face without filters or
sunglasses so you know what i look like
here's me doing an activity that i love
and i want you to ask me questions about
it so you're really painting a picture
you want to have variety you want to
have clear photos that show us who you
are we don't want to be playing where's
wally and wondering which one you are in
a different picture and really you're
putting yourself out there so that
somebody can see who you are know what
you look like and most importantly
you're creating a hook that they can
grab onto and then engage you in a
conversation okay so dating apps um
one of my core beliefs is that everyone
who is single that i know should be on
dating apps and only about half of them
are and there's a few common objections
that i get when i try and talk people
into making accounts on dating apps um
can i just throw a few of them a few of
them at you and i would love to hear
absolutely okay um
dating apps are just for hookups what's
going on there
i work at hinge hinge is really about
getting people off of the app and onto
relationships i know that's sort of a
tagline but in the two years that i've
been there i've really found that to be
true we're obsessed with helping people
go out on great dates there are
different dating apps that serve
different purposes but if you're someone
who's really looking for a relationship
a so are a lot of people on certain apps
like hinge and b you should feel free to
be up front from the beginning about
what you're looking for so we just ran
this fascinating experimented hinge
where we showed 12 000 different users
four profiles some of the profiles said
they were looking for something generic
you know kind compassionate adventurous
some of the profiles said
i am looking for a long-term
relationship what we found is that if
the person in the experiment was also
looking for a long-term relationship
they were much more likely
17 more likely to send the person who
was looking for a relationship a message
because they were like great you've
taken the guesswork out of this i want
something you want something i'll
message you
if the person looking at the profile did
not want a relationship they were 10
percent less likely to send that person
a message and that actually saves you
time on both ends you get more messages
from the kind of people you want to hear
from and fewer messages from the kind of
person you don't
and so a lot of this is just being bold
being courageous being up front from the
beginning whether it's on your profile
or the first and second date about what
you in particular want to get out of
this experience nice love it so
objection number two is dating apps
focus too much on the superficials and
as a sub point to that it's mostly guys
that i speak to about this uh guys are
systematically um
uh
shall we say
shafted in the dating market because
um you know there are so many more guys
on this app than there are girls and
i've tried it a couple of times and i
never get any matches and then i look at
one of my female friends and they're
getting freaking 100 matches a day like
ugh as a guy dating apps are not for me
there are issues where dating apps can
reduce you to this two-dimensional image
that people are evaluating and without a
lot of context they might immediately go
for looks one thing that hinge just
released is these voice prompts and this
is a chance for people to be silly they
could do an impression of their favorite
cartoon character they could play you a
silly song that they've been writing
they could you know do a celebrity
impression whatever that is and it's a
chance to bring more authenticity to the
profile and so i'd say in general i
think the future of what we're going to
be seeing with dating apps is wanting
more information whether it's more video
more voice more interactivity so it's
not just like hey here's a piece of
paper with bio data on it that your mom
showed you and you have to say yes or no
i want to go on a date with this person
but really it will feel more like oh
i've seen you on social media i get a
sense for how you move through the world
i get a sense for what you look like
what your voice sounds like i have an
immediate response to who you are and so
i would say for those people what can
made you on their end to bring their
more full self to the profile and then
also in their own behavior on the app
how can they try to give more people a
chance because if we focus too much on
height
or age we're actually filtering out a
lot of people who could make great
potential partners
on the note of what you put on a dating
profile um
i so on on my hinge profile about two
years ago
one of the prompts was um
i think you know
the i like a
perfect date night or something like
that
and
i said something like uh
singing a duet uh of uh i see the light
from tangled with you
um
that's so cute and i showed this to a
few friends and a few a few guy friends
who by their admission had had a lot of
success on apps like tinder and hinge
and they said bro
you can't be saying that
that signals that you are not very
masculine it signals you are insert
homophobic slur here that is not the
kind of thing that women want in a man
so suppress that aspect of your
personality on the dating app and let it
maybe come out
preferably never but like if you have to
do it like further down the line when
they've gotten to know you already
what's what's your take on the
suppressing the less masculine
characteristics of myself on my on my
dating app profile
i totally disagree with your friends
first of all
one exercise that people can do is think
about the three messages that they want
to get across on their profile so
let's say and i'm you know we're just
getting to know each other but let's say
i wanted you want people to know that
you're curious about the world
that you
are intellectual and like having deep
conversations and that you also have a
silly side
so i might say to you okay if those are
you and actually how how close am i and
why don't you tell me what your three
things might have been i guess i i never
really thought of it as like what are
the three things i'm trying to get
across
um yeah that's just as an exercise maybe
you can tell me you know before you met
the person that you're seeing now if you
were like when somebody looks on my
profile and they give it 20 to 30
seconds
in an ideal world they'd come away with
three these three ideas about me and
then we would reverse engineer a profile
that shows those things oh that's
interesting okay so so
immediately the thought in my head is
that there is a difference between
the way i'd want to come across
authentically to people that i'm
interested in being friends with and the
way i'd want to come across authentic i
would want to come across to people that
i'm interested in being romantic
partners with and maybe and i don't know
maybe i've just drunk the kool-aid of
this like toxic masculinity stuff for
too long but
i would be very hesitant about wanting
to signal that
i really enjoy singing disney songs even
though that's true uh i it's it's like
stuff like that that i would be i i
would hesitate in saying that this is
something that i i want to put forward
because maybe it doesn't create create
the right kind of image
does that make sense i understand what
you're saying so i think what you're
saying is if it was just who am i in the
world in a platonic setting you might
put the disney thing in in a romantic
setting you might not but before we go
into the how to get it across just and i
know this is not the easiest exercise
but just like for the romantic context
three things you'd want them to know
about and this could be something like
family super important to me it could be
you know you have a love for a certain
football team like just what are three
things where you're like i want to give
off this message okay
so it's a good question let's think
about this so one of them would be
something like
i
am
quite
uh i had a phrase i'm i'm quite keen on
my own stuff and i would like the sort
of relationship where we're both like
we're both doing our own stuff we have
our own projects and we come together to
like build each other up but where
one party is not like reliant on the
other party for their happiness
uh or what's to that effect and
at one point i had in my hinge prompt
thing i think the the prompt was uh the
ideal relationship looks like dot a dot
or something like that and that's a good
problem and my answer was
where we spend 90 of our time doing our
own thing and 10 of our time doing stuff
together and that was very very
polarizing i showed that to like all my
female friends were like whoa you sound
like a sociopath what the hell is wrong
with you
but i was like hey this is you know if
someone wants to sign up to be in a
relationship with me this is probably
something they should probably know
where and also 10 that's like 2.4 hours
a day that's quite a lot of time do
people in relationships spend more time
together than that people are like no
but it just makes you sound weird if you
boil it down to a mathematical ratio
so that's one of them
um
i think another one would be
i would probably want to signal some
level of social status success prestige
whether that's the cambridge university
on the thing whether it's the doctor on
the thing whether it's at one point i
even had me holding up my million
subscribers youtube plaque as like one
of the images which again was a bit
polarized some friends were like oh
that's a bit weird why would you signal
that and other friends were like oh if i
saw that i'd be like oh my god this
person's interesting they've got a
million subscribers on youtube that's
unusual
so i think i'd want to signal social
status in that kind of sense um
and
i would want to signal something like
yeah sort of a playful a playful side um
maybe not disney maybe something else
along those lines maybe me having a big
smile uh with hanging out with friends
or playing board games or like being
obsessed with harry potter or you know
that that side of things um potentially
as a fourth option like the music stuff
because i'm big into singing and piano
and guitar and stuff and i just love
that [ __ ] so
i don't know i think i would want to
signal some of those some of those
things that was great and thank you for
being honest i feel like a lot of people
wouldn't have said that second one but
would feel it people who make a lot of
money might want to signal that they
make a lot of money and you'd have a
nice lifestyle if you were with me but i
feel like people aren't always honest
about that so i appreciate that you said
like social status is something you're
proud of and you'd want that person to
know so
those three things all
summarize them as the first one is
you're looking for a relationship with a
lot of independents where you both bring
a lot to the table but you have separate
and fulfilling lives and then together
you also have a fulfilling life but it's
not codependent the second one is you've
worked hard you've been successful and
you feel like you bring that to the
table and then the third one is you also
have a playful side which comes out
maybe through harry potter or playing
games or just spending time with family
and friends or music great so we would
start with those three things and then
we would say how can we use your photos
and your prompts and maybe your voice
prompts on hinge to get that across and
so
for the first picture i would probably
just say a really high quality headshot
of you and maybe it's something that you
have from your professional life with
that camera that does uh you know the
blurry background and even that is kind
of it's you know uh
subtly suggesting to us like you're sort
of an important person then in one of
your prompt responses you can talk about
you know started as a medical doctor
transitioned to being a youtuber and a
podcast and your favorite way to spend
time is thinking about ideas and talking
to interesting people right you could
have something like that but then you
could have a hook in there like what's
the last great book you've read or
what's the last skill that you've
developed and so you are already
signaling what matters to you but
creating a conversation opener where the
person can say i really want to give you
this
uh
this book recommendation i really want
to engage with you about this idea or
this podcast or this philosophy
then for
the
status one i think you could have
um i think the million subscribers one
thing that would worry me is are you
going to be attracting the type of
person that really focuses on that but i
think that you can use um conversations
and first dates to filter that out
basically you don't want to have people
that are just social climbers and then
the silliness one i think that's super
important because people are going to
say well with those first two how do i
know that this person doesn't take
themselves too seriously which is a
common thing that people want and so you
could have a video of you juggling
poorly and all the balls fall down and
it's just like i like to excuse me i
like to learn new things but i'm not
very good at this or
a video of you singing or
something like that and so that's a
long-winded way of saying i actually
think the disney karaoke one is a really
good idea because with the balance of
the full profile i am professional i am
successful i have over a million youtube
subscribers
it is totally fine to be like and also i
have this side of myself that likes the
movie tangled and will sing with you and
so i think out of context maybe somebody
will say oh women like someone who's
masculine and decisive and all this
stuff but that's not just one part of
you you're this whole person and so i
love that one i think it's surprising i
think it's specific i think it opens a
conversation to say i won't sing that
with you but i will sing a frozen song
with you and so i think it's much more
about understanding how you want to be
portrayed versus trying to fit into a
cultural context in which disney could
be seen as being a beta some of these
ideas i just don't think are helpful
oh
oh that's very interesting okay so um
what are the
the bro okay
there are some kind of somewhat
universally attractive factors that
girls look for in guys and and vice
versa and and one thing i've always been
always been curious about is
to what extent
do should
me as a guy use the my knowledge of what
the generalization and the averages are
to shape my own dating profile plus or
minus my own personality uh
do you get what i mean
give me an example of something besides
the disney one that you may or may not
include based on this so-called strategy
um
um so
the disney one uh so like
at one point my hinge thingy well one of
the prompts was uh i'm really good at or
i'm the best in the world at and i said
harry potter trivia so again
um at one point i had a photo of me in
my bedroom but the feedback that some of
my male friends said about that is that
those like get pastel colored posters
you've got on the wall with the blue and
white baby blue bed sheets maybe doesn't
quite signal that you're a man who's got
their life together and it kind of looks
more like a teenager's room rather than
a successful man's room um
things like that where
it's like i
could choose to put that in there but it
maybe wouldn't signal the i don't know
masculine nurse the confidence the
successfulness that what i'm a grown up
person who's good to go the life
together kind of vibes
i'll start by saying i do think that it
depends on what you're looking for and
what the other person is looking for so
i have a close guy friend who went on a
date with this woman they had known each
other for several years they were
friends but they were exploring being
something more and they went on this
great date and she went back to his
apartment afterwards and she said
your towels have holds in them your
bathroom is dirty the sink is dirty
there's garbage overflowing from the
trash can you're not signaling to me
that you're ready for a serious
relationship and i can't waste my time
helping somebody grow up and i don't
want to continue seeing you romantically
and that story stuck in my mind because
he felt like he was ready for a
long-term relationship but some of the
actions about his life and how he was
how he was you know keeping his space
didn't portray that and so yes people
are taking in lots of signals i think
that if you are unemployed or
underemployed people are going to judge
you based on that i think that
hygiene and the way you keep your space
yes people judge you on that and so i'm
not saying that that stuff doesn't
matter but in reading between the lines
and what you're saying i feel like
you're investing
a little too much time in the
how will this be seen
and how does this one picture in a
vacuum portray me and not enough time
saying i can paint a picture of myself
on the profile then very quickly i'm
going to get into a conversation i'm
going to ask good questions i'm going to
be interesting i'm going to be
attractive
i'm going to work hard to make that
person feel seen and i believe in my own
ability to create a relationship and so
i
i hope you don't take this the wrong way
but i feel like some of what you're
saying is a little bit of like what i
see on reddit from people who are trying
to hyper optimize specific things and i
think trying to say like what do women
want and how do i become that and you
know this isn't masculine because a pale
poster would be that it's like actually
maybe
all the guys who have these so-called
masculine photos of holding up a dead
fish that's a huge turn off and that's a
cliche and people literally will swipe
past that and instead if you're just a
bold curious person who says this is
what i'm about i'm a layered person with
complexities i bet you are too that is
going to stand out that is going to be
more unique that is going to have more
hooks and so i think
that while i also am an optimizer and i
also like to have strategies and do
things the right way there's something
about love in which it's two deeply
complicated people who have to come
together choose each other and continue
to choose each other and i think for
every moment that you're spending
thinking about the baby blue sheets and
the pastel posters you could be spending
that
either becoming a more interesting
person which i know that you spend a lot
of time on or
contacting more people or going out on
more dates or actually learning by
engaging i think that the profiles
matter but at a certain point
it's less about optimizing the
individual pictures and more about
learning and updating and that's sort of
the scientific method right it's not
just ask your million friends what you
think the outcome will be but actually
test it so if you have that picture on
there and nobody comments on it for
weeks maybe it's taking the place of
something that people could comment on
and so make your best case scenario
profile see how you do switch out your
first photo switch out your prompts and
your end goal is to create a dynamic
story with variety which with a lot of
hooks that people are commenting on or
liking or asking you questions about
amazing yeah that makes so much sense
and
after all of this like uh
experimentation i i i landed on a
profile that had i showed it to my male
friends two years ago they would have
been like oh it's not very masculine i
was like you know what it's fine like
that's not the vibe we're trying to go
for here we're trying to go for someone
who would kind of appreciate what i'm
actually like rather than a sort of
false persona of
what reddit and you know these other
books and websites tell me that girls
would women women would potentially want
um
and that ended up working reasonably
well so that was good ding ding ding
yeah i loved everything you said i would
write it down and i would underline it
and write you're trying to portray who
you are and get one person who's
interested in you you are not trying to
hack an entire gender and figure out
what the most number of people would
like it's how do you get the person who
you would most like to like you nice
okay so we've got the profile where
we've matched with a few people we've
got hinge premium because why not
such a time saver um this is another
thing this is another hill that i die on
with a bunch of my friends like why
would you not like you're making decent
money you work at mckinsey why would you
not pay 17 quid every six months
it just begs but anyway i think about
that all the time in terms of like how
much would you pay to find the love of
your life and for a lot of people you
know depending on their pay scale it's a
lot of money so why aren't you putting
money behind that why aren't you
you know investing in some good date
outfits whether it's paying for a dating
app or even i have a friend who runs an
incentive program where if you
it's actually through her dad if you set
her up on five dates either five dates
with one person or five dates with
different people some combination he
will send you this gift basket from
nuts.com
which i just think is so funny and
random but why it works is
psychologically it makes you feel like
okay this person's really serious about
dating
she's willing to go out with whoever you
set her up with and there's an incentive
and so it makes me put in the extra
effort to set her up and so if anyone's
listening and feels motivated put your
money where your mouth is and offer an
incentive to your friends to set you up
it might just make the difference
between them saying yes and i'm actually
doing it
yeah so on that note there was a blogger
that i that i follow um his name is
tynan uh he was he was actually featured
in uh the game back in the day uh the
book oh wow um he was he was one of the
people in the house but he ended up kind
of growing out of that becoming like a
personal development blogger type guy
and
building businesses and things and i i
interviewed him on this on one of these
like streams about two years ago uh he
had a thing that when he turned 30 he
posted to his mailing list saying look
i'm serious about getting to know
someone if you introduce me to the
person i end up in a long-term
relationship i will i will a long-term
relationship with i will help you tick
off any item on your bucket list
and he got a bunch of like inbound that
way and when i when i heard about that
that really resonated with me because it
really was a case of put your money
where your mouth is and take this
seriously but then i mentioned it to
some people and they were like that's a
bit weird it's dating shouldn't be so
systematic and stuff like
what what the hell is wrong with you um
i don't know if you could if you got
that like the whole like scientific
approach to dating and stuff do you get
that pushback that like oh it's supposed
to be more natural than that
first of all i have chills from that
story because it's so clever like i love
that it was at the milestone of turning
30. i love those to his email list i
also think tick something off your
bucket list is just such an amazing
prompt and probably better than money
because it like helps you release it and
say like what's my bucket list and
what's holding me back and maybe even if
you don't win that contest or whatever
you still might make progress on it but
for the general question yes people ask
me all the time why are you trying to
apply research to something that's
organic and how can you bottle up love
so my response to them it's actually the
first paragraph of my book is that yes
love is natural and we're born knowing
how to love
but dating isn't
dating in the modern sense was invented
at the end of
around 1890 so this is a relatively new
concept in terms of the span of human
history and then dating on apps is
around a decade old with um swiping and
all that being extremely new and so part
of it is just
having humility around the fact that a
lot of us are just making this up as we
go along this is not something that we
know how to do second of all in history
people would help you right there was
the matchmaker or maybe your father
would
have you marry the person next door so
that your parcels of land connected or
he would trade your hand in marriage for
10 camels there was all these other
people involved it's actually a really
new concept that you on your own define
all of these characteristics of your
life including who you marry and so
people need help second of all there is
academic research on this we talked
about this there's research on
attraction research on do opposites
attract research on what makes for a
long-term compatible relationship
why wouldn't you look at that if you
were going to make a nutrition plan or a
financial plan you would look at the
research why is love something that has
to defy logic and defy science and so
i'd say this is something that you care
about and you want to find someone great
and not get divorced why wouldn't you
invest in knowing the information out
there it can only empower you and you
can take the parts of it that are useful
and you can ignore the other parts nice
love it um just like while we're on this
on on this tangent i wanted to ask like
what
what is the kind of uh broad
brushstrokes of what the research says
on
what is attractive and what are the
qualities that make for a good long-term
partner can you you mentioned there's
research on on both those so the people
who i admire the most in this field are
the gottmans so john and julie gottman
highly recommend people check out their
stuff and they've been doing research
into the topic of love for
over four decades and they run this
institute called the gottman institute
and some of their most interesting
research happened in this space called
the love lab so what they would do is
they had this apartment
sort of in a bnb that they would invite
couples to come to and this apartment
was decked out in ways to monitor them
and yes people knew that they were being
monitored and so it would have cameras
and microphones and it even had this
thing under the chair called the
jigglometer that would see how much your
chair moved and maybe how anxious you
were it was testing your urine there was
tons of data being collected what they
would do is they'd have a couple there
over the weekend and they would observe
them
and what they did is they had couples
there for a period of time
and then six years later they saw who
are the couples that stayed together
happily what they called the
relationship masters and who are the
couples who were unhappily together or
had broken up they called these the
relationship disasters and they did all
this research to understand what were
the behaviors that we saw
in that first setting that might have
helped predict who was gonna thrive
versus breakup
and so the most important thing that
they found is this concept called bids
and a bid is a verbal or nonverbal
chance to connect so a very obvious bid
might be me saying to you hey i had a
hard day can we talk about it i'm being
very explicit that i want to talk to you
but it also might be me reading an email
and signing loudly
and i want you to say to me what's wrong
and so it's this chance to connect and
then they measure
how does your partner respond and
there's three ways the partner can
respond turn towards you asking a
question reaching out trying to engage
turning away from you that could be just
ignoring you or turning against you just
saying why are you making so much noise
you know that i'm trying to get work
done and so what they found is that
for the relationship masters they turn
to get they turn towards each other 86
percent of the time so they're making a
lot of bids and they are accepting each
other's bids and the relationship
disasters they only turn towards each
other 33 of the time so you and i are
talking about these very strategic
things about like profile and
masculinity and how do you portray
yourself but what the godman's would say
is that the secret to a successful
long-term relationship is small things
often having a habit of
trying to connect with your partner and
noticing when your partner's trying to
connect with you and taking that time to
really
invest in each other turn away from
distractions and really say this is
what's going on with me what's going on
with you and just it's those daily
habits and those daily moments it's not
the trip to hawaii or the
you know exciting new sex toy it's about
constantly investing in each other hmm
so
this segues nicely into something else
that i i wanted to talk to you about and
that is
the extent to which this
and bid stuff
is different when you're dating versus
when you're in a relationship
and what i mean by that is that um
you know so a few
a few a few months ago i was i was i was
going on a few dates and we were kind of
chatting a bit by whatsapp messages
afterwards
and uh obviously i turned to some of my
female friends to help me respond to
some of these messages uh as as one does
um and one of the points that i of
feedback that i got from some people and
this was not everyone but but some
people was that
i was coming across as too keen and my
response rate was too fast and
she said that thing and she asked you a
question and then you
responded to it but then you like overly
elaborated on that response which
signals to her that
you have nothing better to do with your
time that you're begging for her
attention she you know in the dating
stage she wants to feel as if she's
doing some of the work therefore you
need to tone the hell down your response
time and kind of be less
like a beggy about like the way you're
responding to her
uh this was some of my female friends
there were other female friends that
were like that's completely terrible
advice you're just having a normal
conversation like screw all of that
what's the what's the solution here
okay i am giggling and covering my face
because this is such a hot topic that i
could talk about for hours everything
you're saying i could talk about for
hours but
i feel
honored to get the chance to bust some
myths yes so remember right i work with
people one-on-one i have the anecdotes i
have the stories i also work at hinge
which means i have access to millions of
data points around how this stuff works
we did this fascinating research on the
topic of responsiveness and what we
found is that if somebody messages you
and you respond within the hour you have
a much greater chance of having a long
conversation and even going on a date
and so all of this nonsense around play
games match how many hours she waited to
respond and then you do the same
none of that
helps you get into a relationship with
somebody who's a good communicator who
talks authentically who is somebody who
you can be yourself with all of that is
a way to just maximize a game and you're
not trying to play a game or win a game
you're trying to find a long-term
relationship and so what i would say is
remember
you are talking to a bunch of people she
is talking to a bunch of people right
it's a noisy bar with a lot of
conversations
one of the best ways to stand out is to
just engage in a conversation with her
and try to make it as synchronous so
talking at the same time as possible and
so the data on this is very clear
responsiveness on a dating app
is a useful strategy because it helps
you get into the conversation and stand
out and one thing that you can do
strategically is pretty early on say
something like you know i'm more into
texting can we transition to text and
something about getting from the busy
dating app inbox to the more personal um
texting or snapchat inbox is that now
you're in the place where her friends
are and you can help stand out and so
generally in that place i would say you
want to be playful and you want to play
but you don't want to play games
i remember
a few
probably uh probably earlier this year
um
i was on one of these apps this was on
mismatch actually um
that i interviewed the founder of on
this podcast in episode number two if
anyone wants to check it out um
there was a girl whose profiler came
across
who i wasn't like like like i wasn't
massively sold on the profile i was just
like um kind of lukewarm towards it but
one of the prompts that she said she
said like you know what's one fact about
me that will surprise you or something
like that and she said i reply
ridiculously fast to messages i was like
oh okay and then i commented on that as
being like just testing or something
something something like that and she
replied within like 10 seconds and we
ended up going on a date and actually
having a great time and like
you know the spark wasn't there and and
and all this and that but like we
actually had a great conversation
through the app
went on the date and i was like wow
this person really stands out by
actually being quick at responding to
messages because otherwise it's like you
send a message you wait 18 hours nothing
happens you know etc etc like it was
such a breath of fresh air um and i just
never i guess i guess in my head because
as a as a guy in this scenario i think
guys are more sensitive to the a girl
will be turned off if you come across as
too keen i i i didn't quite
sort of put two and two together and
think you know maybe if i were quicker
at responding people would would vibe
with me a bit better
i want to make a meta point because i
think
a lot of what you're bringing to me as
questions are things that are like
there's an old wives tale or there's
general cultural wisdom that you should
do x and many of my answers are no
i would advise doing y and so i think we
could go through all of those different
ones but i just want to make this as a
general point which is that if you were
to start a youtube channel and all you
did was study the most popular youtube
channels you might just end up creating
a copy of the most popular people done
with worst lighting worse audio
equipment worst guest and you are less
good at interviewing right you're just
doing a copy of something else and you
blend into the background
maybe you want to do something different
maybe you want to innovate maybe you
want to stand out
and i think that sometimes when we're
looking at so many profiles doing
something surprising creating that hook
showing your individuality is the best
possible thing that you can do because
if you see 10 dead fish pictures in a
row and then you see a guy who says i
spend most of my day on the computer
because that is my job but at night i'd
love to play a board game with you that
is different and so for her you know
you're talking about men don't want to
seem like they are too available so they
shouldn't respond quickly well women
also want to don't want to seem like
they're too needy so in writing that
she's really standing out and i think
it's it's not that there are no rules
but i think in general these rules make
us focus on the wrong thing when the
things that we should be focusing on are
be the best person you can be
invest in your communication skills
learn how to talk about hard topics like
sex and conflict treat the other person
well and when you know that you're not
interested in somebody break up with
them in a kind respectful and firm way
and move on i think if we worked on
those foundational skills of human
connection and less time on well how
long did she spend to respond to this
message and do i seem needy i i think
that that's investing the wrong energy
in the wrong place
yeah and this is exactly the side the
the the stuff i tell kind of youtubers
as well
stop focusing on the wrong things focus
on the stuff that's going to move the
needle i actually making videos and
slowly getting better over time one of
the things you talk about in the book is
the idea of um prom date versus life
partner and if i kind of paraphrase uh
there are different things that we're
looking for in a prom date where maybe
we're focused on how attractive are they
and how adventurous and risky and
interesting do they seem whereas there
are different qualities that we look for
in a life partner which is more like in
growth mindset uh emotional maturity the
ability to fight well and communicate
clearly etc um
how
when when it comes to like first and
second dates how would you go about
sussing out the more deeper qualities
where uh in in the context of a date
where like everyone is kind of putting
on their best behavior you would think
great so yes i love this concept and i
think that it's really important in
people's personal development to make
that shift from the prom date to the
life partner and unfortunately some
people just think oh that happens with
time but no i think you really have to
make a concerted effort to say like yeah
that guy's really hot and it'd be fun to
sleep with him but he's actually
not that reliable i don't know if he'll
show up when he says he will i'm
constantly worried about him letting me
down
and actually what i'm experiencing isn't
chemistry it's anxiety and so that's the
prom date and now i'm going to reject
that person and move towards a life
partner and so for anyone listening or
watching i would say
if you consistently find yourself with
prom dates i want you to focus on the
life partner in terms of how to find
these people early on i think you can do
it as early as the profile the messaging
and first dates and it's really about
coming up with some questions that help
you elicit certain responses and so
something about the growth mindset is
people with a growth mindset feel like
they can try new skills safely and even
if they're bad at them that's totally
fine because life is about getting
better as opposed to somebody with a
fixed mindset who says you're born with
these skills and you can't improve them
so a question i've been encouraging
people to ask over the last two years
while we've been in the pandemic is
something like
what's something that you were bad at
that you've gotten better at or have you
invested any time especially during
lockdown in working on any skills and
you know you can iterate that on that
and make it sound more casual but just
understanding is this the kind of person
who says i have a lot of alone time i'm
going to learn to speak spanish or did
they just spend more time playing video
games right like what is this person's
orientation toward growth
in terms of loyalty a really important
quality
you can ask these people you know do you
have friends from different stages of
your life or what is the best gift
you've ever given there's chances where
you say
this is the quality in the person i'm
looking for this is the question that
strategically helps me understand if
they have that and then i'm actually
going to listen to their answer and see
how it jives with me and not just say
well actually all their answers were
terrible but they're so hot i'm going to
ignore it no no that's a prom date thing
listen to their answers and say is this
the kind of person that i want to keep
getting to know or do i want to find
someone who's more aligned with the
qualities i'm looking for
yeah one of the one of the things that i
i accidentally did this was before i
read the book is that um
on this uh with with this girl who i'm
i'm now like i guess in a relationship
with well i feel that still feels weird
to say um on our second day we went to
play top golf which is like this cross
between 10 pin bowling and a golf
driving range and neither of us had ever
played golf before and so i messaged her
being like hey do you want to try the
skull thing and she was like i mean i've
never played golf before i was like me
neither let's just give it a go and she
was totally up for it and that was one
of the things that really stood out
where i was like she was totally cool
with actually trying out this new thing
being okay with looking like a bit of an
idiot playing both of us playing the
sport that we never played before um and
so i really liked that as
um a thing and then i read the growth
mindset stuff in the book and i was like
oh i kind of accidentally kind of
selected for that particular quality
which was kind of nice i i love that
story so much i think there's so much to
that first of all you were brave and
suggesting something that you weren't
good at there might be somebody out
there who says oh i only take people on
dates to things i'm really good at so
that i look good in a certain light no
what you were showing is that you're fun
and spontaneous and willing to try new
things and be bad at them and she was
also willing to do that so i think
that's a great idea
i talked before about dating like a
scientist part of dating like a
scientist is having a hypothesis testing
it and then looking at the data and so a
big thing that people have been asking
me in the last year or so is i want to
ask people if we can do a phone call or
a video date before we meet up but some
people will be turned off by that i
think using what you said um hey on a
scale of
uh this is scary too i'm interested how
open are you to having a phone call or a
video call that could be a cool way of
doing it but i also think just asking
and seeing how the person responds gives
you a lot of data so maybe somebody says
a video call what are you screening me
for a job that's weird no or they say i
haven't done that before but i'm open to
it and so it's each moment is a chance
to see you're putting out
um some sort of stimulus and you're
seeing how they're responding to it and
that gives you a lot of information and
so do the bold thing ask the question
and see if they can roll with it or are
they so traditional and so tied to
certain norms that that freaks them out
well if you don't like that then that's
maybe not the kind of person you want to
be with nice one of the things that you
talk about is the sort of
actively reflecting on a date when you
get back from it
um and i wanted to ask like to what
extent like what are the sorts of
questions that we should be asking when
we get back from dates and to what
extent is like
a sort of checklist approach to this a
good idea because we talk about things
like growth mindset and emotional
maturity and ability to communicate is
that the sort of thing like similar to
how like if you're hiring someone for a
job you want to have like a scorecard
and you want to be able to evaluate each
candidate against the scorecard is this
the sort of person who would be able to
do x to what extent is that like a
decent approach when it comes to dating
and reflecting on dates afterwards
in general i think that
having a checklist is not helpful
because often what's on that checklist
is the wrong stuff it's
height
income perceived success
do we have the same hobbies i think a
lot of times that checklist is based on
what we think matters in long-term
relationships which the research shows
us doesn't matter in long-term
relationships so as a concept i would
say throw out your checklist be willing
to date someone who's not your type it
is very possible that the person you end
up with the person who makes it you
happiest long term is not the person you
thought you would be with that being
said in my book i offer this exercise
called the post date eight
the post date eight is based on research
on gratitude journals so there's amazing
research from many people including sean
acor of harvard that says if at the end
of the day you have to write down three
things that you're grateful for your
brain will actually be looking for them
throughout the day so if you're running
to make the bus and you make it maybe
five minutes later you forget about it
but if you know that at that night you
have to write it down then you're going
to notice it more so what we do at the
end impacts what we look for throughout
so the post date eight is the same idea
i've taken what i believe and what the
research shows matters for evaluating a
date i've turned it into these list of
eight questions things like how did i
feel in my body around this person do i
feel curious about this person what side
of me did this person bring out and then
throughout the date
you aren't looking at their height and
their job you're paying attention to
those things and at the end of the date
you ask yourself the post date eight to
decide do i want to see this person
again and so it is a version of a
checklist but it's a checklist designed
to help you focus on what matters not
what doesn't nice and i wonder if you
can give some examples of like what are
some of the questions in the post
sure so
from all the research that i've done and
even the coaching i've done since my
book has come out this one of what side
of me did this person bring out is huge
because it helps you understand great on
paper brings out a bad side of me i
don't want to see them again that's a
really helpful insight another one is
this idea of do they energize me or
de-energize me so
there's an activity called a penthouse
in a basement person you think in your
life not even in a romantic setting who
is my penthouse person who when i'm with
them do they bring my energy up do i
feel creative do i feel inspired so for
you who's your penthouse person he's my
penthouse person uh i can think of a few
university friends i think my brother is
one of my penthouse people which is why
we kind of decided to start a podcast
together um my current housemate is a
penthouse person definitely
i love that yes so you have this
penthouse person that's another helpful
benchmark and you have a basement person
somebody who makes you feel depressed
down de-energized and so just asking
this question did i feel more energized
or less energized after the date helps
you understand where that person falls
and helps you get closer to finding a
penthouse person because of course the
person you end up with in a romantic
relationship you want them to bring out
that inspired capable creative part of
you
and so it's really helping you
understand what stuff matters what stuff
to pay attention to and it ignores
things like
did i think they have an impressive job
and do we have enough
hobbies and comments stuff that people
think matters but really doesn't nice
um
one of the things that you talk about in
the book is to always go on the second
date uh what's the what's the deal with
that
yes so
there's a whole idea in behavioral
science of defaults and so whatever we
create as a default sticks with us so if
a
hamburger place has fries as the default
most people will stick with that and get
the fries if a hamburger place has a
salad as a default most people will
stick with that in general we stick with
what the default is in these rules of
thumbs
the next thing is that in dating i think
we put too much pressure on the first
date some of the best people i know do
not perform well on first dates they are
awkward they are not comfortable they
are not good at small talk they are more
introverted this is harder for them but
these are people who would make great
long-term partners and so how can we
actually take the pressure off the first
date and say first dates are almost a
warm-up round it's
uh do i like the sound of your voice am
i attracted to you do we have something
to talk about and i'm going to assume
that we're going to go on the second
date pending that nothing crazy or
terrible or unsafe happens on the first
date and that way if you go in assuming
you'll go on the second date you're
giving people more of a shot and it's
easier to find those diamond in a rough
people who get better over time and one
of the things i talk about throughout
the book is this idea of [ __ ] the spark
go after the slow burn the spark is
somebody who gives you instant chemistry
they make you feel so attracted to them
like you've known them for a million
years but honestly a lot of sparky
people are
charismatic but also narcissistic
they're focused on getting you to fall
for them but they're not actually asking
themselves if they like you the spark is
something that you can chase that burns
that burns out quickly instead you want
to find this slow burn someone who you
like more and more over time your
appreciation for them grows and those
are really the people to go after and so
some of my friends who are in the best
relationships that i admire they had
terrible first dates but either because
i told them to go on a second date or
their mom told them to go on a second
date they gave that person more of a
chance and so
you will find some great people if you
make the second date the default
i really like that yeah like uh having
having that as a default meaning that if
something's disastrous happens on the
first date it's not like we're saying
that oh my god you have to go on a
second date and it's contractually
binding but more like hey it's a default
and that actually probably would change
your behavior on the first day as well
because now you know it's not so big a
deal being on the first because by
default if they're you know if they
consent you'd want to go on a second as
well
totally and there's this concept i talk
about about the evaluative versus the
experiential mindset so the evaluative
mindset is are you good enough for me
where did you go to uni
what are your table manners i'm
constantly judging you against this
rubric in my head and saying are you
good enough the experiential mindset is
i'm going to be in the moment with you i
am going to be looking at cues for how i
feel and if i'm having fun and am i
laughing but i'm not judging you i think
we just do so much better when we are in
the moment having fun letting time pass
versus when we are constantly evaluating
someone and even what you said before
about having a job description and
measuring somebody against this i feel
like as a culture one of the biggest
mistakes that we're making is we're
saying let's take what works at work and
let's apply that to dating and that's a
mistake this is a date this is not a job
interview if you are showing up with a
corporate mindset and a spreadsheet and
you're giving me 15 minutes to give your
investor pitch you're going to go on 100
dates and it's not going to work out
because that is not what leads to
connection and so yes it's great that
you are killing it at your job but if
you are applying all of what you do at
your job to dating you're probably not
having the connection that you're
looking for oh this is so interesting
experiential versus evaluative um
so this really resonates with a bit
because um
again earlier earlier this day earlier
this year when i was like actively
dating
um one of my female friends would always
ask you know
how how was it and i'd be like yeah
that's pretty good we know we had a good
time we vibed i think we get on um and
she was like no like i'm i and this was
like okay what do you what do you like
about her i was like oh
i don't know um
i mean i guess we vibed and we got on
and
it was it was a good time and she was
like hang on mate you're doing this all
wrong you want to be going in with a
in a way a checklist of these are the
qualities i'm looking for you want to
design questions that that sort of suss
it out and you want to be in a way
treating this like a job interview so
that when you when someone asks you what
you like in the person you're actually
able to talk about it and i was like
what this this seems weird like if you
ask me what i like about my friends i'd
be like
i mean i i probably can't list off a
checklist of things and this friend was
saying oh that's just because you're not
like emotionally mature enough yet once
you become more emotionally mature then
you'll be able to know what it is you
like about someone and be able to
articulate it rather than saying oh we
vibed um
what's uh what's what's going on there
any thoughts
i'm laughing because i almost feel like
i'm saying some things that are in
conflict but in my mind they're clear
but we should probably go through them
and clear them up and so for example
when i walked you through that exercise
about what are the three things you want
to communicate to me that's just saying
like this is like your one shot to have
a billboard about you and i do think you
should be strategic but then in other
ways i said i don't think you should
optimize the color of the posters on
your background and so it's like you
want to invest you want to put your best
foot forward but you don't want to spend
too much time right in that last 20 you
want to focus on the 80 percent that
matters and so for this situation i
could see somebody listening or watching
and being confused and saying well she's
saying you have a checklist but it's a
post-state 8 it's not a checklist about
that person's qualities what i would say
for this topic and for what your friend
said is that so often people come to me
and they say logan i know exactly what i
want i just need your help finding that
person then they go through this list of
he must be over six feet tall he must
make at least six figures he must love
travel he must have parents who are not
divorced and they go on and on and on
with this list and unfortunately the
older people get when maybe they should
becoming more flexible because the pool
is smaller the list gets longer and they
say well i've waited this long he better
be perfect and that's not a good
strategy how i think about it is this
so-called type of yours these qualities
that you're so sure that you need how
has that been working out for you maybe
you've dated plenty of people with that
and it hasn't worked out because what
you think you want is not what's
actually going to make you happy long
term and so my husband is a
five foot eight
red-headed
vegan engineer
do you think that if i made a checklist
those would be all the things on my list
no that wouldn't have been on my list
but he is brilliant he is hilarious he
understands me better than i understand
myself we have the most fun together we
see the world in a similar way i
couldn't have made a list to find my
husband but when i started hanging out
with him and i saw the side of me he
brought out and i found myself thinking
about him all the time and we had the
best jokes and the best conversations i
realized this was a good match for me
and so take your checklist take your
so-called type rip it up be willing to
say i'm going to date different types of
people and see what side of me they
bring out so be strict about how you
want your partner to make you feel and
the life you want and be flexible about
how they show up in the world and what
qualities they have is it reasonable to
go on a date and not really
be able to articulate what you liked
about someone and instead just that you
vibed or is that just uh
yeah i love that i mean i think you
really nailed this question when you
said i couldn't tell you everything
about my friends that i like i think if
i'm i mean i have a lot of close friends
and i think if i think about them what i
might say is something like
i don't have to censor myself i can say
exactly how i feel i can be petty i can
be unkind i can be selfish i can be
self-absorbed and i can just say this is
what's going on with me give me space to
vent and they will hold that space for
me and it will be totally fine think
about people who i don't vibe with as
much and it's because i think that
they're judging me or i feel like they
want something from me or our
relationship isn't balanced and so it's
really humans are complicated if humans
were less complicated there would have
already been an algorithm that perfectly
predicts from day one who out of the
millions of people
in your country or city you should date
the reason that doesn't exist is because
we have years of habits years of trauma
we have different characteristics we
have different personality traits and so
the only way to know
if you're a good match with someone is
to spend time with them and see how you
feel around them can you imagine
bringing them into your home and and
building a life with them and so you
don't have to be able to articulate she
said this thing which implies this thing
which goes against my list you could
just say i could imagine myself talking
to her for hours or i found that my
brain was making interesting connections
and i felt energized from our
conversation um
nice i really like that i feel i feel
partially vindicated in these in these
conversations
yeah i mean it's funny i feel like i'm
yeah
i feel like i'm judging your friends but
i kind of am because i feel like your
friends are bringing a lot of cultural
baggage to you saying here's the rule
and you're breaking it and what if i
said to you there's no rule the number
one thing is be a good person and pay
attention
speaking of rules uh there is another
friend who i've not talked about yet um
who so i'd i'd been on a but i'd been on
a first date uh with someone
and i was very concerned about the whole
first kiss situation and like when when
do you go for the first kiss
and i brought this up on a group holiday
with some friends i was just like yeah i
don't really know like uh you know i
guess when the moment's right but like
and and one of my friends said no no
in my experience if we haven't kissed by
the third date then it's a no-go that's
a massive red flag and then suddenly i
was like oh [ __ ] like there's a there's
a three-date rule and i even went
through the motions like uh sort of
rehearsing this with some of my friends
be like okay if we're sitting by a park
bench and we're sitting on the bench
then then how do i how do i go for the
first case if we're sitting in the car
how do we go like all of all all of all
of this kind of stuff um
and describing it now and for someone
listening to this it probably seems
really bizarre
but there is i feel like there is some
element of truth where it's like uh if
well
you know
having having pulled a handful of female
friends about this they do say that oh
well if he hasn't made a move by at
least but you know by the third date it
kind of suggests that he's not really
either he's not really into me or he's
just not that confident and therefore
it's it's a no for me how do we approach
this uh three date rule situation when
it comes to the first kiss and i guess
the broader question is a more meta
question about rules and regulations
when it comes to dating so this is a
question i get a lot and i wouldn't say
that i
necessarily have a rule on it i would
just say it's really hard especially it
became hard after 2017 with the me too
era because there was a lot of feelings
of i
want to be bold but i don't want to be
creepy i want her to know i'm interested
i don't want to ask for permission in a
way that seems weak and so i just want
to acknowledge that for everyone i think
this is really hard then you add into it
a pandemic where being in someone's face
breathing on them sharing a kiss with
them is actually potentially putting
them in danger this has just become a
very difficult conversation
and so
my advice for my clients is that
there is a
sexy and confident way to say can i kiss
you and so part of it starts with body
language what did you say what is that
way
i think that it's first of all i think
that there's body language i think you
can see you know if you're close to
someone do they seem to be leaning into
you
if you touch their arm do they seem to
like it you know you can whisper in
their ear i think that there are some
subtle flirtatious things that you can
do to say you know i'm going to get
closer to your space and seeing if you
respond well
the pandemic does complicate a lot of
this because i think some people would
be like i don't want you to be anywhere
near me but what i would say is that at
the end of the day you could say
something like i really want to kiss you
how would you feel about that or
um
you know what are your thoughts on
kissing on the first date or
just something where it's like oh no
wait that second one was exactly what i
said i said
really how would you feel about kissing
on the second date
yay i love that yeah maybe i'm inspired
by your earlier thing that i really
liked about saying you know what are
your thoughts on this i think it's a
clever
way of basically getting at someone's
thoughts but you're obviously saying
can i kiss you and so i think the number
one message i want people to take from
this is
in general asking for consent is the
right thing to do and there's a way to
do it that's both confident and sexy and
doesn't ruin the moment and it's up to
you to experiment with different phrases
that feel right for you but you should
neither assume that somebody wants to
kiss you or assume that somebody doesn't
want to kiss you the best approach here
is to actively find a way to let them
know that you're interested in doing
that and seeing what they think
one of the things that i wanted to talk
about in in in this video that's coming
up is
what are the things that make for a good
or bad date in your experience i have
some tips that help people create great
dates dates that lead to connections so
the first tip is that
the date doesn't just start when you
show up the date actually starts hours
before when you get into the mindset so
my version of an old quote is whether
you think the date will go poorly or you
think the date will go well you're right
and so what that means is that your
mindset matters so if you're
transitioning from a hard day at work
where your boss was yelling at you and
going straight into a date you're not
going to bring an excitable present part
of yourself you're gonna bring a
stressed part so i want you to
proactively take time between work or
whatever else you're doing and the date
and getting into a mindset that might be
to bring yourself with perfume because
you're turned on by sense it might be
listening to a pump up playlist to get
your energy going it might be working
out what are the things that you can do
to cultivate the right mindset for a
date
the next thing is what are you actually
doing on the date so many dates are
these job interviews where i sit across
from you and i say what did you study
and why and how many siblings do you
have and what's your five year plan and
you know what who cares that doesn't
really affect our ability to be in a
relationship together it's dry it's
boring
coffee dates that feel like job
interviews all fade into the same
why can't we do an activity together why
can't we meet up in a park and run
around and try to pet five dogs why
can't we go to
a street with a lot of dumpling places
and create our own dumpling tour and
figure out our best one why can't we
have an experience together where we're
doing something we're having fun even if
we don't have a connection at least we
had a fun experience together and it
takes the pressure off so designing a
date with a lot of fun and playfulness
another thing is really listening
so often we have our cell phones out and
there's great research that shows that a
conversation is much less deep and much
less empathetic when our phone is out
because what happens is i think
as soon as your phone blinks you're
going to check it and i might be in the
middle of something deep and personal
and i don't want that to happen so i'm
just not even going to go there so put
your phone away turn it off put it under
the table
ask questions that help you connect
versus just waiting for your turn to
talk so there's this concept called a
shift versus support response
a shift response is when um you say
something like i'm going to adopt a
golden doodle puppy and i shift the
attention back to me and i say oh i've
always wanted a puppy but i don't have a
puppy because of my job a support
response is i say why do you want a dog
have you ever had a dog before how did
you choose that breed it helps you go
deeper into your story support responses
are really great for a date because in
the end people care about how you make
them feel
and what people what makes people feel
good is when you make them feel
interesting versus you being interesting
so it's much less about sharing stories
that make you seem cool and much more
about asking them questions that make
them feel important and then my last tip
is end on a high note there's amazing
research from the behavioral economist
daniel kahneman which found that when
people are getting colonoscopies
they'd actually rather get a colonoscopy
that's slightly longer but ends in a
less painful way because we
disproportionately remember things based
on how they end so even if you have a
mediocre date you can save it by ending
on a high note you can ask someone for a
kiss and give them a great kiss you can
order dessert you can give them a
meaningful compliment you can show them
a surprise mural that they've never seen
before and so really think about how can
i end this date in a meaningful and fun
and memorable way
nice that's a great stuff um
earlier today i posted on instagram and
on twitter basically saying i was
interviewing you and we we've got a
bunch of questions in from uh random
people in the audience um so if that's
all right can i chuck some of these at
you so
let's start with the uh the girlfriend
ones because obviously you know i need
to prioritize her
um i love it so she says um
oh okay
it's got three actually okay the first
one what are your top tips for becoming
a better life partner to someone else
i love this question and it's something
that i've been thinking about a lot i
don't know exactly if i'll write a
second book or what would it be about
but
this is one of the main things that i'm
considering so my first book in many
ways is about how to choose the right
person
and there's almost an implication that
okay there's all these people you can
get whoever you want and how do you
choose among them but the truth is many
of us
are not necessarily who we want to be or
we wouldn't even necessarily be good
partners right now and so i think what
needs to go along with that is how to be
a good partner
and so in the book in the chapter called
go for the life partner not the prom
date i talk about this idea of loyalty
and how you want to find somebody who's
with you for the ups and the downs and
in that chapter i quote my sister's
speech
or no i quote um
yeah
in that chapter i quote this article
from about a decade ago that my sister
loves
um which is from this woman who's an
oncologist so she's a cancer doctor and
she's talking about how
her friends say i want to find a guy who
loves long walks in the beach and i want
to find a guy who loves dogs as much as
i do and what she says from being an
oncologist is you want to find a guy who
will hold your purse and what she means
by that is that she sees different
husbands in the cancer treatment ward
some who kind of hold the
metaphysic uh the metaphorical and
literal person some who don't that you
want to find this guy who's going to be
there with you and i i quote that in
there so after
the book but before it came out
my then fiance now husband was diagnosed
with a rare form of bone cancer
and so what's been happening for me is
all of these things in the book that i
talk about what you should look for in
somebody else i am now having to be that
partner so my husband went through three
extremely invasive surgeries including
uh but then
below the knee leg amputation
um a knee replacement like really major
surgeries and i have literally been the
person holding the purse or in his case
his backpack or his fanny pack and so
what really resonates with me about your
girlfriend's question is that we spend
so much time thinking how do i choose
but we should probably be spending as
much or more time saying how can i be
the person that gets chosen so anyway
just wanted to start with that preamble
of why this is so relevant to me it
broke yeah it really comes down to kind
of being being there for the person
yeah so that was just one example but i
would say how to be a better life
partner so some of it is just knowing
yourself and knowing your stuff so what
keeps you in the safe zone where you're
happy you're confident i like this word
that i invented called confident it's
when you're calm and confident how do
you stay in your confident mode and what
are your triggers so for some people
let's say they're anxiously attached
their trigger is when their partner's
traveling and isn't in touch they get
upset and they move into the danger zone
so
what i would recommend to that person is
know your triggers know what you need
and learn how to ask for it so really
part one is going deep inside yourself
and knowing yourself and doing the work
another thing is learning how to have
card conversations so
sometimes people say to me oh i met this
guy we're getting along so well we never
fight that's not something that i think
you need to optimize for lots of very
happy couples fight fighting is about
being passionate my mother-in-law who's
a therapist says when couples tell me
they don't fight i also say do you not
have sex because for her and her mind
those things go along it's about having
friction and working through stuff so
learning how to have hard conversations
learning how to say things like i'm sure
you're familiar with non-violent
communication but when you think of that
at the moment
i'm like oh really yeah i love nvc i i
use it all the time so for people who
aren't familiar with it it's a framework
for expressing yourself in a way that
helps you
get heard and helps you
kind of speak in a way that really
expresses what's going on for you so the
format is when you
insert a specific thing that happened
i felt and you have to use an emotion
word so it can't be something that's
judging them like
i felt
left behind it would be something like i
felt sad i felt enraged i felt depressed
whatever it was
because of my need for blank so you
explain to them why this matters so
recently i had this in a work
conversation where i said when i wasn't
part of that decision making it made me
feel
sad because of my need for inclusion and
then you say in the future i request
that you blank and you say a specific
request that they can agree to or talk
to you about and so just learning things
like that like how to communicate how to
stand up for yourself how to have
boundaries all of that is super
important
another one is what we talked about
earlier around bids so making bids to
connect with your partner and turning
towards their bid so if you are
working really hard and your partner
clearly wants to talk do you make a
choice to close down your laptop and
talk or do you say not now i'm in the
middle of editing and i'm in a flow
state or maybe you can just say i'd love
to hear that story can we talk in 20
minutes and so these small decisions
that you're making and i think another
one that we haven't talked about that
much is sex
dan savage has his concept of ggg this
is his secrets to good sex so it's um
good
which means being skillful how can you
develop your sexual skills giving how
can you be generous in bed and game how
can you be willing to experiment or give
your partner what they want within
reason and so i would also invest in
learning how your body works how
somebody else body works asking for what
they want giving feedback because
while
some very happy relationships don't have
great sex lives for many people that
does matter and how can you take your
own sex life into your own hands
oh any recommended resources on that
front
so there's a lot of great books that
help
women understand their bodies more
there's a lot of great women books that
focus on pleasure there's a book called
she comes first
there's a book called
come as you are
there's a wonderful book that is maybe
on people's radars called mating in
captivity
and that's about the tension that many
people feel between wanting to feel
comfortable and safe but also wanting to
feel adventure and excitement and how
you know the mating captivity is such a
clever title because it's like how do
you keep the sexual spark going in a
long-term relationship which is
genuinely something for someone because
there is part of sex and lust that has
to do with novelty when you've been with
someone for a while novelty fades and so
what can you do
to really
engage in that oh one other resource is
a friend of mine started a company
called dipsy which is
erotic audio storytelling so it's not
like listening to porn it's listening to
a sexy story and why i love that is the
whole idea is that you're investing in
your imagination you're closing your
eyes you're seeing this visual you're
imagining these two people meet the
tension is building up and i do feel
like we live in a very visual porn
addicted world where people have lost
some of that imagination
and if you can actually remove some of
the visual
and focus on your imagination your
desire
explore your kinks that is only going to
help you when it comes to
having sex with other people and having
good sex
amazing um
what a great answer
uh very blushing
[Music]
this is great i love this
i've got some new books to add to my at
my kindle library
okay so next question uh it seems that
understanding how to find and create
great relationships is a key life skill
do you think this life skill should be
better taught to children teenagers
young people and if so how
i think all the time about the fact that
we should be teaching people more life
skills in school so this is everything
from
how to save money for the future
why you should pay off your highest
interest loans first to
nutrition
exercise maintaining good relationships
i really feel like if you look at what
makes a happy meaningful life
it is not algebra and it is not grammar
and those things matter and you know i'm
a nerd i went to harvard i care about
all that stuff but when i actually think
about the things that i learned in
college that impact me it's things like
how to speak in a way that's persuasive
how to get your point across how to work
with others how to be a leader a lot of
these soft skills really impact the
bottom line and so i absolutely think
that we should be teaching
people from middle school high school on
about healthy relationships because
you can think about your relationship
history as a garden and so throughout
your life you're planting these seeds
and then those seeds develop later and
so even if you're 20 years from a
traumatic incident
there was something that happened that
is now part of your garden and so if
from a younger age we can help people
say this is how to say yes this is how
to say no this is how to ask for consent
this is how to explore your own body
this is what emotional manipulation
looks like
this is the difference between secure
and avoidant and anxious attachment and
so i think we would help people save a
lot of heartbreak and a lot of pain
some of which is necessary but not all
of it is by teaching them these skills
earlier
yeah that's kind of what i'm
semi trying to do on this youtube
channel uh on my youtube channel which
is that
less from a perspective of
i know what i'm talking about and
therefore i'm teaching you these life
skills and more from a perspective of i
have no idea therefore let me talk to
people who are experts on things like
relationships and love and health and
wealth and things like that and let's
kind of learn together and be sort of
students together in this on this
journey
yeah i'm so happy that you're doing that
and it also reminds me of a course of
the school of life and i had the
opportunity to go to a school of life
conference i was just so inspired by
some of the ideas that were shared there
was an exercise that helped people have
better conversations where you got to
choose the superficial or the deep and
it was just so fun to see a concept come
to life through videos and exercises and
um breakout rooms and i was like yes
this is what we need to be learning
nice love it um final question from my
girlfriend who shall remain unnamed uh
in the book you talk about how much we
all change over the course of our
lifetime what are your top practical
tips on being able to grow together in a
relationship over time there's wonderful
research from dan gilbert of harvard
called the end of history illusion this
idea that we stopped changing and so how
he experimented with this is he asked
people of different ages how much did
you change in the last 10 years how much
do you expect to change in the next 10
years and people inevitably said i
changed so much from 20 to 30 i changed
so much from 40 to 50.
i'm already i've become who i'm going to
be i'm not going to change and that is
incorrect we are all constantly changing
and so if you think about
marriage and monogamy and long-term
relationships there is something a
little bit irrational and ridiculous
about it i'm gonna choose a partner at
27 that i expect to find interesting and
attractive and
warm at age 77. like do you know what i
mean there is something sort of
irrational about it but
there are ways to build relationships
that last and so one of them is just
understanding that relationships are
going to go through ups and downs and so
in the book i talk about this idea of a
relationship contract or a relationship
charter which is something that you put
together with your partner and you say
here's what matters to me here's what
i'm about here's where i want your
support here's how i want the
relationship to be
and you can check in on it from time to
time and you should choose this date in
advance you could say six months from
now let's check in or six years from now
let's check in it helps make sure that
you're staying on track
it also provides this space for you to
say what's working and what's not and so
i think a lot of the questions that i
get from people in relationships are
things like
my partner's constantly doing x maybe i
should just accept it how do i know when
something's worth bringing up or not and
my feeling is that resentment is so
toxic there's this saying resentment is
poison that you give yourself
and i really agree with that so a bet
the best way to avoid resentment is
bringing things up as they happen so
instead of saying over the last six
months every single weekend i've asked
you to do the dishes and you haven't
done it and i'm going to go crazy it's
after this happens a few times say hey
i've noticed that i
am doing the dishes a lot of the time
maybe i'm missing when you do them i
know you do a lot of other stuff around
the house but
next time that you see the dishes need
to be done will you just proactively try
to do them or you know you can use
non-violent communication but really
addressing problems as they come up
planning for the future
knowing that change is inevitable and
creating space for you and your partner
to talk about what the relationship was
what it is now and where it's going nice
yeah one thing that we do which we kind
of started from uh in inspiration from
the book is like a
every few weeks uh relationship review
type thing
a series of 12 questions some of which
are from the book some of which which is
made up and it's genuinely really
helpful to just like specifically ask
questions like the first few are kind of
what's what's going well i like um
what did i do this week that made you
feel loved or appreciated and vice versa
stuff like that and then later on it
gets to you know is there anything that
i did that kind of made you feel not
great or sad or annoyed in any way what
can i do differently and
it's actually been really useful and
every time i've mentioned this to
friends who are in relationships they're
like damn i thought that was a little
bit weird when i first heard about it
but actually i wish i could have these
conversations on a somewhat regular
basis with my partner because it seems
to yeah it's a sort of thing where
otherwise it just tends not to come up
and stuff can i guess fester for a long
time
yeah and honestly i feel like that's one
of the main things that's emerging from
our conversation today is things that
seem initially weird or forced or cheesy
really work and it's like the same way
that if you are going to the gym a lot
you might write down what your exercises
are and check out your gains and look
back from a year ago and say i'm much
stronger and i can do this many more
reps why can't we apply rigor to our
relationships and so why it's great to
build a habit around it is that neither
you nor your girlfriend needs to say
sorry to nag you but i really want to
talk about this it's like no no it's
built in and so the calendar the date
the recurring event holds that space for
you and neither of you has to nag the
other one it's just like every three
weeks we have this check-in
yeah um how are things with your husband
now
yeah my husband thank you for asking my
husband's doing really well he wrapped
up treatment a few months ago he's
rebuilding his strength he just got back
into the climbing gym which was a big
um emotional milestone for him he has
more energy his beautiful red hair is
coming back yeah he's doing well and
it's been just super interesting we've
been together for seven years and just
to see a person who you know so well
go through something like this and then
also to see how he's changed because in
general i feel like you shouldn't assume
that
you know sometimes people say to me like
i like this guy but he's he's not really
this do you think he'll change and i'm
like no i don't think you should bank on
that but i actually have felt with my
husband like he's in many ways a new
person
any any any ways in particular that come
to mind
yeah with his parents he's just much
more patient i've noticed that he just
has more patience for
you know physical disabilities for
people who get
tired more easily there's just all these
ways in which like he's a very smart
very athletic talented person so prior
to this adversity many things in life
had come very easily to him and i think
just having to work harder to move
around in the world having less energy
going through chemotherapy all of this
stuff has just given him so much
compassion for other people's struggles
and so what i find is sometimes people
will want to say to him oh this thing
happened but it's so small compared to
what happened to you i won't burden you
with it and he says no no the opposite
is true i have so much space and
compassion for whatever you're going
through more than i did before i had
experienced this myself
wow that's very interesting and has that
kind of manifested in your relationship
as well
yeah i think our relationship is
completely different i really feel like
we are
i think i'm a different partner i have
had to be way more responsible there's a
part of me that sort of likes to be
well i don't know it depends on the
scenario but there's a part of me that
likes to be the more fun loving one but
like prior to his diagnosis i hadn't
really liked driving and i hadn't driven
in about 10 years it just wasn't a super
comfortable driver and when he was
diagnosed he was like we're getting a
car and you have to learn how to drive
again like you're going to need to drive
me to and from chemo there's gonna be
emergencies which there were you have to
learn how to drive and i just did it i
had to figure it out and now i'm an
extremely confident
driver and it was just one of those
things where like i had to step up
he also was somebody who wasn't good at
asking for help he's talented he's
independent there were moments where he
really needed help
and i had to pay attention to his cues
and he had
to be willing to ask for help so for
example
there was a really dark moment where you
know everything that could go wrong went
wrong and things were really scary and
there was just all these signs that
things were going poorly and i was
supposed to go
see my friends and family the next day
and this was a trip i had planned for a
long time and
i kept saying do you want me to cancel
do you want me to cancel and he said no
no no and then finally i said this is
ridiculous i am canceling i can't leave
and then he was like oh i'm so relieved
you're staying
and i was like i wish you could have
said to me please stay and then we
talked about can we have a code word for
that and we just went through so many
intense emotions around you know two
people are in a dynamic then a drastic
train
bulldozes and careens into you and now
you have to redefine your dynamic
but i think that we've done that in a
really healthy way
and any questions that we might have
around
are you in it for the long term can i
trust you are you gonna hold my purse in
the cancer ward i feel like we've
definitely answered and so we're we're
truly all in and there's just such
deeper trust than there ever was before
yeah yeah it really sounds like you've
kind of both grown through the
experience and i guess
you wouldn't
kind of
wish it on anyone else but with all
these kind of traumatic experiences
that's kind of the seems to be the
silver lining
yeah there's a wonderful book called
stumbling on happiness that by dan
gilbert who are you familiar with that
book yes yeah i read it a few years ago
um yeah yeah what's the key message
there's a bunch of things and stumbling
on happiness around what we think will
make us happy versus what does make us
happy one of the key things is is that
we all adapt to our surroundings so you
think being really rich will make you
happy but actually you just get used to
having that amount of money and so when
you ask people how much will your life
change if you
um
win the lottery versus how much will
your life change if you become a
quadriplegic in both situations people
overestimate the impact because the
truth is after about a year or so you
sort of adapt to your circumstances and
so when all of this happened with my
husband
i
emailed dan gilbert who i know a little
bit through harvard and some other
research in my book and i said you know
this is what's going on
everything assembly on happiness has
made me feel better and he wrote back
and he said i'm paraphrasing but as
crazy as this sounds
when you're talking about this with your
with your grandchildren decades from now
you might very well say this is the best
thing that ever happened to me because
it will just put so many things in
perspective it will help you grow and so
no i wouldn't wish this rare form of
bone cancer on anyone but i do think
that my husband is a more patient
grounded
empathetic loving person and in many
ways this experience really helped him
rise to the occasion and change for the
better well thank you for being so like
open and talking about this this it
can't be an easy thing to discuss i
guess
it's not but it's also just happening
right now so i'm an external processor
so even just being able to share it with
you and kind of see how i feel now
versus how i felt six months ago it's a
helpful
it's a helpful exercise and checking in
with myself oh excellent um
we've got a sort of i guess on a
somewhat related note a few questions
from from instagram rnc snapshot
something uh are humans designed to be
monogamous
ooh this is a loaded question so
they're
i am not an expert on this topic but i
can lead you towards some interesting
resources so there's a book called
saxodon
that argues that we are not meant to be
monogamous
there is a biological anthropologist
named helen fisher who i really admire
and i interviewed for the book and she
has some issues with sex at dawn
i would encourage people to look into
her work to look into his work to
really understand kind of the
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
psychology perspective on this and for
people to come to their own conclusions
that being said
i feel like anyone who's trying to
disrupt relationships i really admire
that i think that we have this
one-size-fits-all toaster model of
relationships where if you think about a
toaster you buy it at the store
you plug it in
and at
best you hope it doesn't break you never
expect it will get better yeah why can't
we think about relationships more like
an iphone where there's software and you
can constantly be updating the software
and you can be getting more apps you can
be deleting apps and it's something that
going back to what we said the end of
history illusion how can you
adapt and grow as the relationship
adapts and grows and so i would say i
have lots of friends that are in
ethical non-monogamy relationships
who
float in and out of them who have found
that this is
something that they love to think about
and talk about and so i personally
believe that there is a lot of space to
explore different relationship
structures
nice
um
a real underscore fee says do you think
that a person who loves you must accept
you exactly as you are i think about
this question a lot because one thing
that people ask me is do you need to be
a whole person before you can date or
can somebody complete you and i feel
like these questions are all kind of
circling the same thing which is
should you be with someone who loves you
for who you are or should you be with
somebody who sees the potential in you
are you complete without them are you
complete with them i think there's a lot
of ideas in here and so i would say as a
baseline
acceptance is a huge part of
relationships because if you get into a
relationship expecting somebody will
change i think you're setting yourself
up for disappointment a few examples of
this i've seen are relationships where
somebody's much older and somebody's
much younger and the older person takes
on a mentor capacity and is constantly
trying to help that person become better
i think that creates a power imbalance
that can be
really hard to maintain over time and
what happens when that younger person
says i want to be your equal i don't
want to be mentored anymore that can
change the dynamic another example i've
seen is
when people are looking for a project
and not a partner so they say ah this
guy is unemployed and not ambitious but
he's so talented i'm gonna help him get
his act together it's like don't you
wanna be with someone where the two of
you can run together not where you're
dragging somebody behind you and so in
general i would say
it's okay if somebody can see the best
in you and try to help you
self-actualize and become a better
person but that should come from a basis
of acceptance where even if nothing
changes they'll still be very happy to
be with you
i am ray j rapport says i have a crush
on my best friend but i feel if i
confessed it to her it will ruin
everything do you have any advice on
this
my husband and i met
when we were in college when we were
undergrads and we know this because we
became facebook friends that day
we didn't meet again for seven years
until we were both
working at google and he came up to me
by the shuttle stop and said hey didn't
you used to date so and so and didn't
you go here for college
we then
spent a year being friends he was
tutoring me in r a certain coding
language and after that i
developed a crush on him i was working
with the dating coach who helped me see
his potential and finally i helped shift
from friends to more by saying i don't
have plans on friday night you should
ask me out
and so i feel like i am living proof
that friends can make the best partners
and sometimes the most eligible single
person around us is hiding in plain
sight we just have to
identify it and then take the leap
that being said there is a huge risk
here you can make someone uncomfortable
you can ruin a friendship so a couple
ways to do this one
is
i don't drink i'm not that into drinking
but you could get drunk with someone and
say crazy idea have you ever thought
about
us being together or my mom always asks
why aren't you dating so and so you'd be
such a good match what do you think
about that so you can kind of tiptoe
into the conversation
um and then i think you should also just
make it very safe for them to say i
don't feel that way about you and so i
think it's worth bringing it up but
create a space where the person can turn
you down without putting the friendship
at risk
makes a lot of sense
um
ahmed says how do you detach yourself
from a person after a breakup breakups
are so hard there's all this research
that shows that when we are going
through a breakup
our bodies are actually experiencing
withdrawal the same way that we would be
if we had been addicted to drugs so the
nucleus accumbens a part of our brain
lights up in the same place from
love withdrawal as it does from drug
with all so if you're feeling an intense
amount of attachment and pain and trauma
that is completely normal
a few things that you can do to get over
a breakup
one of them is
you can focus on the negatives of the
relationship so there's an experiment
where they had people journal about what
are all the reasons why the relationship
was bad
that can help you really focus on
the reasons why you're lucky to be out
of it instead of looking back at looking
back at it with rose-colored glasses
another journaling exercise you can do
is write
um all the reasons why the breakup is
good what are the ways that it will help
you what are the ways that you can move
forward
you can also engage in what's known as
rediscover yourself activities so those
are things that imagine you were dating
someone and they didn't like jazz or
they didn't like going to the beach or
they didn't like visiting your parents
for the holidays what are all the things
that you can do now that your partner
didn't want you to do and reinvesting in
those activities helps you discover
yourself your own identity and things
like that
another thing is there's a
concept about making meaning and i
imagine you've read viktor frankl's man
search for meaning yeah great book
yeah so a lot of the concepts in there
are about the fact that it's not that
time heals all wounds it's that meaning
heals all wounds and how can you make
meaning of something so how can you sit
there with your journal with your
therapist with your friend and say this
is what i learned this is what happened
here's what i'm going to do moving
forward and it's in that moment of
saying i'm going to do this next time or
i'm going to incorporate this into it
that you feel that you've grown that you
create a narrative that this was an okay
thing that happened it wasn't a waste it
was a learning opportunity and in that
making meaning you feel empowered to
move forward and do
you know find a better relationship the
next time
uh so quick question number one what
advice would you give to your younger
self
i would say to my younger self
find places where you feel like you
belong because you will be at your
happiest and most confident
when you
feel like you have when you feel like
you belong who has had the biggest
influence on your career the person
who's had the biggest influence in my
career is dan ariely i talked about his
book predictably irrational
not only did the opportunity to work
with him at google allow me to write my
book which is applying behavioral
science to dating but he just really
changed my entire perspective on how to
live so for example dan is extremely
into mentorship if he meets a college
student who has a question about the way
the world works dan will go out of his
way to respond to that email send them a
voice note engage anytime i've asked dan
for help he goes above and beyond he
just his
true nature is to be extremely generous
and think i am lucky i have a lot of
opportunities how can i help other
people do that
another thing that dan does is he lives
experimentally so he might say okay i
want to eat healthy i'm going to make a
rule that i don't eat bread how does
that impact my life okay i'm gonna make
a rule that i go running every day so
he's constantly thinking about how he
wants to live how he wants to show up in
the world and running experiments and so
that's really impacted the way that i
live because things like moving into a
commune was not on my bucket list it was
not on my husband's bucket list but i'm
willing to give things a try and see how
they sit with me because i understand
that
we don't necessarily always know what
stimuli will make us happy and so it's
worthwhile to test that sick yeah he
sounds like a great guy i think i read a
few kind of blog post summaries of
predictably rational but i need to read
the book and then email him for an
interview that would be fun
um
what is what is one tip for someone
looking for success one tip for somebody
looking for success is to lead into your
strength i think people spend a long
time trying to become well-rounded and i
have found that that doesn't necessarily
work so for me i'm not particularly
quantitative it takes me a longer time
to do
data analysis to
understand a graph something like that
right that's just not necessarily like
my strength but i have some really spiky
things around pattern recognition
communication persuasion
making people feel comfortable and so i
mentioned before that i met my now
husband because he was teaching me this
coding language r well you know what i
didn't learn r but i did get a husband
out of it and so i don't spend my days
trying to get better at the things i'm
bad at i try to get i just spend my days
trying to become best in class at the
things that i'm really good at and then
i supplement the things i'm bad at by
paying people or asking friends
or crowdsourcing and so lean into your
genius zone awesome uh what is the first
what does the first and last hour of
your day look like
i wish i were more disciplined with how
i spend my time i'm working extremely
hard and i do feel like i am firing in
all cylinders but i could be a little
bit more disciplined so the first hour
of my day unfortunately is probably
doing some scrolling checking some
messages sort of looking at the inbox i
wish that weren't the case then i listen
to the new york times podcast the daily
i make coffee and then because i live on
the west coast but i work for hinge
which is east coast i'm basically
jumping into work right away
i do know that i am an extreme morning
person and i'm most creative basically
anytime before noon so i try to carve
off a few hours in the morning to do
what i call creator work so writing
brainstorming generating ideas dealing
with messages that i've been avoiding
but
you know sometimes things can get in
that way but yeah and then in terms of
the last hour of my day
probably talking to my husband and then
reading nonsense articles on my phone
until i fall asleep fantastic um
what uh material item under around about
a hundred dollars uh could you not live
without
i have a portable phone charger that i
really care about that i've been
carrying around for a long time and i
know it sounds silly and i should
probably be less addicted to my phone
but there's just something about having
this portable phone charger with five
charges on it where i'm like i can leave
for the day and go on adventures and do
everything i wanna do and know that i
can charge my phone and i never want to
be that person who's you know going to a
starbucks and trying to find a cord and
doing this and that so yes i really love
my portable phone charger nice um what
is a book that you would recommend to
anyone other than your own there's a
wonderful book called far from the tree
by andrew solomon
and when my
husband and i first started dating i
came up with this idea of a syllabus and
a syllabus was a syllabus of books that
helped somebody understand your soul so
we each gave each other a few books
to have the other person read and one of
mine was far from the tree so far from
the tree is about 12 chapters each about
an extraordinary childhood have you read
it or you've been like no i've just
bought it on kindle so i'll start
reading it tonight okay great so
basically one chapter is you know
children who are deaf another one is
children who are
the result of rape another one is
children who are criminals children who
are prodigies children who have
schizophrenia children who have autism
and they're basically exploring what is
childhood like for them what is the
experience of being a parent and it's
really about understanding sort of
extraordinary
ways of
you know having children and i think it
just creates so much empathy for the
fact that there's a lot of different
ways of being and in the book
andrew solomon talks about this idea
where imagine that you think you're
going on holiday to france
and you get on the plane and you think
you're going to france and it lands and
they say welcome to holland
holland is a perfectly great country
that somebody would be lucky to visit
but it's not what you expected but you
have to embrace holland and so with
everything that happened with my husband
sometimes we would turn to each other
and say welcome to holland and it means
this is where you are this is the
reality make the most of it nice that's
really cool i will i'll check them back
out um
if you lost everything so let's say um
you get cancelled you lose the job book
gets boycotted everywhere what would you
do uh career-wise and life-wise this is
a fear of mine i mean i think anyone
who's existing in the public space who's
saying things off the cuff who does a
lot of interviews like i worry about
this all the time and i i do feel like
there's you know probably 20 of my brain
that's monitoring what i'm saying and
trying to be media savvy so i would say
definitely on my mind
i think if this were to happen i would
just
really invest in my friendships and
relationships and i would say
my life in the public persona my my life
in the public sphere is over or it's
going to be over for a while but what
actually matters is things like mental
health physical health spending time in
nature
helping people and so even if i were
canceled that doesn't mean that i can't
help people with their love lives it
doesn't mean that i can't come up with
interesting theories and frameworks and
so i would say it's a fear of mine and i
hope it doesn't happen but i do think it
would be a helpful opportunity to
really go deep with myself and the
people that matter most to me
nice that's really good the this is
something that i i think about in the
shower as well but like what if i do
yeah
what do you think
what's your answer to that
i
i kind of think that i would um yeah
again
not do the public thing but uh
and i'd i'd figure out a way you know
also the whole friends and family thing
they're probably they probably
understand and still be friends with me
i'd probably figure out a way of
building some sort of
internet content type business that was
anonymous or pseudonymous so there's a
bunch of interesting youtube channels
that explore really cool topics but you
don't know who's behind them because
it's just a voiceover um so i'd be able
to kind of exercise my love of like
reading writing and teaching just not
with my name plastered over the internet
that's really smart
we'll see yes
yeah uh what what quote or mantra do you
live by
so before we talked about victor frankl
the holocaust survivor who wrote man
search for meaning and he has this quote
between stimulus and response there is a
space in that space is our power to
choose our response in our response lies
our growth and our freedom so for me
this is something i think about all the
time is how can i actually take that gap
between something happen
something happening and respond instead
of reacting and so i am a sensitive
person
certain things that happen to me i can
get really upset or frustrated or
anxious or enraged or whatever and so i
really try to create that gap for myself
where i say hmm
my mom gave my sister this purse that
she's had for years that i really would
have wanted and i feel left out and i
feel mad at my mom and i want to send my
mom an angry text about it
you know what my mom didn't mean
anything by it my sister probably asked
and my mom didn't know and it was no big
deal i'm going to sleep on it i'm going
to take space and so i really have been
trying to become a person who responds
rather than react and victor frankel
who's a hero of mine and a hero of many
people has helped me understand the
power of taking that beat taking that
space fantastic and final question uh
journey or destination
journey nice everyone says that i love
it
okay how about this i used to be really
into adventure and i used to spend a lot
of time traveling and
going to different places and trying to
work from different countries and then i
realized it's so much more about the
people that you're with so my answer
which is not your question is community
over adventure
nice that's really good um
there was a there's there's this artist
who does these like really famous
cartoons
where it's like
so one of the questions that he he
writes is that he you know it's like a
child asking a mentor like an elephant
or something you know
is
what what's more important the journey
or the destination and the elephant
replies the company
oh i love that that's exactly how i feel
yeah that's good that's exactly how i
feel great yeah i'm gonna remember that
fantastic place to leave this logan
thank you so much um everyone check out
the book links in all the things um
anything else that you'd like to share
with the audience before we before we
part ways
absolutely yeah so i have this quiz on
my website loganuri.com
quiz where people can figure out their
three dating tendencies
i also am starting to teach classes
where people can learn alongside me and
other people in a similar dating
situations all that's on my website and
then people can follow me on instagram
and twitter at loganuri
fantastic logan thank you so much this
has been such a joy i've learned so much
and the way that you're so open and
honest about everything is just really
really inspiring um thank you thank you
so much thank you for having me i was
looking forward to this and it
definitely lived up to my expectations
fantastic all right so that's it for
this week's episode of deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are gonna be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the itunes store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full hd or
4k on youtube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye